e
okay good morning everyone the time
being 10:03 we'll get started on the
exec session for S SP
and
um I want to start off with uh um
representative spillsbury representative
spillsbury and representative Ames have
uh been working on this to see if we
need an amendment or what we need to do
with this um and uh we'll start with uh
representative spillsbury and then go to
representative Ames thank you Mr
chairman
uh I believe that the bill is introduced
by Senator Ganon was adequate in its own
way and that uh there are two different
issues that have become
confused that unless we're told
otherwise this morning by our visitors I
think we can strip them back
away the first issue
is who exactly which entity requires an
exemption from the licensing
requirements
and the bill that as it was introduced
was that a non-member
individual which is to say an outside
Auctioneer who's not a member of this
organization having the
auction can conduct the the auction
without a license for that
organization I think that's
straightforward when you look at the
existing statute that this is proposing
to amend that's RSA 3
B13 that statute is within the statute
that um authorizes licensing of
auctioneers and it says very simply that
a member of a charitable
organization can conduct an auction
without a license so this is adding to
that that existing provision identifies
the entities and this leads us to the
second
question the existing St statute 311
B13 says any that that a a member
individual of a charitable organization
educational religious or other
nonprofit and Senator Ganon uses the
exact same phrase charitable educational
religious or other nonprofit
organization in the existing statute as
with this bill there's no effort to
further Define charitable educational
religious or nonprofit
organization they are broadly used
generic terms and I think that's because
the intention of the existing statute
was to be sweeping and to allow for all
of them um so I don't think there was
any need to define those terms and the
existing statute has operated without
objection even though those terms are
not defined so the second element of
confusion that's entered our
discussion is that the Senate amended
their own bill and we've received it
with this phrase in line
four if eligible under RSA 721
Tob so the Senate's Amendment introduced
a cross reference to a statute that
defines uh nonprofit
organizations and when it came to us we
then started to say wait a minute what
about fraternal organizations what about
religious groups what about
churches so if if you were to wade back
in and examine what did representative
jian's Amendment do what did
representative fellow's Amendment uh
propose to do
Etc they are trying to address these two
forms of confusion and it turns out I
believe that when you when you realize
that the broad phrasing charitable
education religious or other nonprofit
is identical to the existing statute
that this is being added
to and hasn't required definition we
could very simply my
opinion amend the Senate bill to remove
the phrase if eligible under RSA 721
Tob and just let the terms charitable
educational religious or other nonprofit
organization stand on their own they're
plain language they can be interpreted
without having to be defined as terms of
art okay and then this leaves us with
the original intent that the subject of
this whole thing is non-member
individuals you can hire an outsider to
conduct your auction without his needing
a license for that purpose
if everyone agrees if our guests
concur I would say we could get a very
simple Amendment drawn this morning to
remove the Senate Amendment and go back
to the original as introduced
Bill thank you and thank you for your
your work on this um over the past few
days representative Ames would you like
to add to
that
well first uh thank you to
representative spillsbury
um I agree with what he said um and um
the um it's really if you step back from
this this
is this is a
um should be a non-controversial
um amendment that uh responds to a gap
in the allance for uh non-licensed
people to conduct
auctions um and it does so without
disturbing the protections that are
already in the statute uh
for uh situations that currently are
allowed for auctioneering by
non-licensed people in uh uh in the
situation where they two are members of
the charity that or the uh charity where
the auction is being held
uh so this expands that and has all the
safeguards in it um and it it shouldn't
be that difficult I think one thing
that's hampered our dealing with this
and our um is that we really had no a
substantive testimony that gave us uh
context to work on this bill and this
certainly is not our field of expertise
we're sort of dealing with a subject
that has to do with license that usually
doesn't come this way so uh we've had to
wrestle with that too but putting that
all that aside it it's a simple matter
and uh we uh I I agree that uh we should
use the language that's already in the
statute for that narrower group that's
already authorized to provide
auctioneering services in a very narrow
context and use that language charitable
educational religious or other a
nonprofit
organization uh to uh Define the arena
within which uh the unlicensed
individual may may function and um and
uh fix the language and go forward and
uh the simple fix is to go back to the
original bill as
filed um and um or to amend this bill as
it came to us and and write in that
language and uh to me that would be
sufficient so I I agree really entirely
with what uh was
proposed thank you representative Ames
thank you uh both for working on this
over the past few days diligently I
appreciate it yes just I I had I had
noted that we didn't have any
substantive testimony but we did have a
uh a letter from Senator Ganon that uh
got submerged underneath all the other
stuff that comes in and didn't come to
our attention until uh we started
working on it this weekend um and it's a
a good explanation of the context and
the background of regulation for
auctioner and services that exists uh so
I just want to point that out I think
you all have received that yes thank you
yes every everyone should have received
that in their email it's a roughly a
two-page uh letter from Senator Ganon um
so with that I would just like to um uh
first mention that on very short notice
um we um have
uh read the last name correctly uh Al Al
buyers um who is um one of the
um original proponents of of this and
also Michael Haley from the uh doj trust
division here to um to just kind of
here if they think that uh what What's
just been proposed to go back to the
original Bill not amended um so first
I'm going to invite up ay if you could
come up and tell us your thoughts on
that
she you'll introduce
herself hi so I'm ay buers um I work
with Senator Ganon on this bill um I am
a licensed Auctioneer working here in
the state of New Hampshire and um to
give a slight background the impetus for
creating this bill is that if you which
you guys wouldn't need to do if you were
to look through all the rules and
regulations of what an auctioneering
license requires and what it is designed
to do it's designed to protect the
seller of items as we traditionally
think of auctions so it's a matter of
how the funds are transferred from the
buyer to the seller the timeline that
happens in how the advertising happens
the care custody and control of the
items from when you take them from the
seller to when they're delivered to the
buyer um the records that are kept for
the sale and um if there's any question
about the items or the property with the
buyer the funds are put into escrow and
held in a place until the resolution is
taken care of if you are working with a
nonprofit and doing a nonprofit
fundraising event for instance easy
thought you're going to the animal
shelter at your hometown and someone is
providing services to raise funds for
that the person providing the
auctioneering services never takes
control of any item never is in any care
cuty in control of any of the funds
never is in control of any of the
advertising and never really has
knowledge or control of where the items
are coming from and never has records
about where the items are going to so
the laws we have in place don't really
apply in any way shape or form to
someone providing auctioning services to
a nonprofit hence the idea of removing
those individuals from being covered
under requiring an auctioneering license
because the laws don't really apply to
what they're actually providing for
services the creation of the bill was
incredibly simplistic to mimic as you
said the current description of what it
was it's basically nonprofits all of us
in our head probably think 501c3 is and
six it's basically what it meant to be
so we just copied the current RSA
regulations um I understand potentially
why they wanted to clarify what New
Hampshire views as a nonprofit but as
you said it's kind of redundant because
it's already what the original RSA and
rules and regulations state in 100
through 500 and that's never been
clarified um and again it uh the current
rules say if you're a member of the
organization you wouldn't have to have a
license but there is a growing body of
professionals like myself who travel
around the country and work solely for
nonprofits and therefore um we are paid
on a flat fee most of us are paid on a
flat fee basis to provide those services
and we would not be members of the
organization they would choose us for
our abilities and to execute what they
need taken care of at their event to
raise the most amount of
funds thank you um yes rep uh
representa to go to the the law what
would prevent you from advising someone
how to run an auction and letting
someone someone in the charity run it
absolutely nothing I do that with some
groups I go in and just do the
Consulting and I don't actually execute
the auction
okay so you wouldn't be covered follow
followup then
so this this laws as proposed wouldn't
really affect you would it no this law
is for those individuals that show up at
the actual event and execute um a live
auction component or what would
potentially also be covered under the
auctioning law of an appeal where you
it's a a request for cash from people in
the organization so if you are not if
the nonprofit is not doing an auction
component then it wouldn't it wouldn't
matter and if you were just Consulting
with a nonprofit it wouldn't affect you
either so there are fundraising
Consultants that are just hired for
their expertise and then someone else
performs the actions at the event thank
representative spillsbury yes thank you
very much I think that was a good clear
description shows how simple this really
is um I would just point out that all of
the Amendments all of the confusion have
related exclusively to the first
sentence sentences the 2nd through the
6th essentially Echo the
stipulations why it is we that we aren't
requiring a uh a license because the
auctioneer is not handling the seller's
Goods
Etc thank you representa um Aly
yes I just want to get clear on the
language
here on does not allow someone who is
not an Auctioneer anywhere to um to do
the
auction so under the current law if a
nonprofit was
to hire an individual I.E pay a person
to perform the auction at their event
and they are
non-licensed one that individual would
be subject to the New Hampshire Board of
auctioneers disciplinary actions and two
the nonprofit could potentially be
subject to some sort of problem because
they were using a non-licensed person it
also technically according to the rsas
and rules regulations the nonprofit
should be
as the the rules and regulation State
putting the lure number if they if they
were to hire an auctioner license
Auctioneer licensed individual put all
that information on their advertising
which none of them do because the
auctioneer is not the important part of
the event it's the raising funds for the
nonprofit so it's also creating removing
some technical barriers that the
nonprofits should be
doing follow up yes
um if I am a member of a nonprofit that
has never done an auction before right
and I read this
language uh within the cont context of
the rest of the auction Heering on am I
going to understand that without a
license for that
organization
means that I don't need that the person
who's going to be doing the
auctioneering doesn't have to have a
license as an auctioneer correct so but
is is that clear from that language cuz
it isn't to
me I would have a hard time answering
that because I've been licensed in the
state for 12 years so I've been in this
for so long um but I think
for a decent amount of nonprofits in the
state of New Hampshire they are aware of
the fact that either it has to be a
member of their
organization that has to be someone
that's licensed or they could they could
have a person who was non-licensed and
non-member but they could not receive
any compensation including a meal they
could not receive anything of value to
perform the
auction is what it currently is a system
we live under re represent
Ames yeah first I just wanted to point
out out that there are consequences uh
right in this statute for um a um for
performing auctioneering Services
outside of uh The
Lure um Arrangement that's allowed by
the set for set out by the statute or
the exception to it for the member of a
charal organization and one of those
consequences is uh any person V
violating the provisions of uh this RSA
and not
exempt that's the membership exempt
exemption shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor yep so it's uh you know
definitely a consequence and then um I
would say that uh you just have to bear
in mind that this is a narrow exception
that the member who who was allowed to
do an auction um
is subject
to limitations I'm looking at the
existing statute that's already in this
statute um that this
individual
um does must not take physical or legal
possession of goods being sold must not
collect or transmit payment for
transactions uh there are a bunch of of
Provisions I won't go through them all
um and uh so it's tightly contained
that's what I want to say yes exactly
yes representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking this
question does the suggestion by
representative spillsbury
in which line is that representative
spillsbury
for pardon me uh to remove the citation
in line four if eligible under RSA 721
Tob would that address what you have
presented to
us yes I you know as a person that
helped draft the original version I've
we intentionally copied the original
language so I feel it's very
okay all right uh yes representative Aly
yeah um we have one of the Amendments
that were suggested by people here
before on on reads and I'll take out the
RSA language non-member individuals
without an auctioneering license may be
hired by any charitable educational re
religious or other nonprofit
organization for auctioneering services
for charity auctions for that
organization is that what we're talking
about yes because that's a lot clearer
for an amateur that's what we yes that
is what we're talking
about
I think
that I would I would uh defer to
representative Ames and representative
spillsbury on that because they're um
they've analyzed this both being lawyers
um we'll also hear from Michael Haley
from the trust division representative
spillsbury you want just a reaction
representative Aly
um I I think that uh the language in
representative fellows um Amendment also
works but it also includes that
reference to RSA 721 that has to be
removed so why not just stick with the
Senate
bill I don't understand
microphone because I don't understand it
and uh my
Democratic party on many years ago now
so it's passed statute of limitations on
got someone who was not a licensed
Auctioneer to do an auction for us we
never did one again uh she was excellent
but um but um I would I read this over
and over again and I couldn't figure out
which organization they didn't have to
have a license from the
original represent
fellows yes I I'd just like to respond
to that and say
that that the sentence is poorly
structured but
so but it's a copy of the stat the um
exception that's right above that that's
for the members so the the this language
wasn't invented for this bill it was
copied from um the T the two you know
this is 2A it's a it's just a slightly
amended version of
two
so while while my thought was when I
began you know that that the sentence
could be better written so could the
sentence that's in section two and then
you start then you're going down the
rabbit hole
because then people are going to say why
are they not worded the same does it
mean something different and this
situation exists all throughout our
statutes that things are not really
worded very well but I I'm
um I I certainly want to hear from the
Attorney General's office but um
focusing just on what statutes should be
referenced in um line four I think it's
what we should just focus on right now
and not try to rewrite the
sentence I think that's why the proposal
is to remove that statute reference
there and go back to the original bill
um any more questions for um
Hy okay seeing none thank you very much
and thank you for coming on such short
notice uh literally she was asked
yesterday afternoon thank
you uh now I'll invite Michael Haley
up uh thank you Mr chair and um
honorable committee members uh my name
is Michael Haley I am the director of
charitable trusts at the Department of
Justice um when this bill was originally
proposed um we didn't uh have any
particular objection to it and we first
reached out when we saw the Senate
Amendment and our concern there was just
that it might create some confusion
about which groups were were eligible we
don't take a position on the bill um and
my specific concern was that the the
existing statute referenced um
referenced religious organizations it
referenced other nonprofits and many of
those are not Charities as defined in
the statute that was referenced so I
thought it just might create some
confusion about who was eligible um
under our uh statute um you're a charity
if you are a 501c3 or if you hold
yourself out to be a charity or if you
uh engage in fundraising for a
charitable purpose from the public um
and that's that's unfortunately
different from what the IRS defines to
be a charity it's different than what
the Lottery Commission defines to be a
charity it's different than what the
municipal um groups Define to be a
charity so introducing a fifth
definition of charity seemed like it
just might create a lot of confusion um
I I don't think that there's any
confusion with the original wording um
and all I wanted to be here today was is
to um make sure that that the groups
that this bill was um permitting to
engage in this activity were the groups
that the legislature was intending so
obviously there's a broad range of
nonprofits that are not Charities the
IRS recognizes um more than uh 20 almost
30 different types of nonprofit
organizations and only one of those is
Charities um so membership organizations
um the c6s that were just mentioned the
veterans groups um labor unions
agricultural groups some credit unions
there's a lot of different types of
nonprofits um so as worded uh this bill
would allow any of them to engage in an
auction and if that's uh what the
committee is is looking to do um I
wouldn't take any position on
that thank you so um do you agree that
if we take out the reference to the RSA
and go back to the original unamended
Senate Bill the intent is still there
that would not be confusing as far as
I'm concerned to Simply remove that
statutory reference okay thank you
representative PL who took the question
out of my
mouth okay uh represent
fellows uh thank you so so I understand
the original bill um what what you're
saying included Charities but it also
included more than what we call
Charities can you help me um with
line
one U because it says charity auctions
by
nonprofits yeah oh thank you for the
question um so yes they're charity
auctions by uh nonprofit corporations so
uh nonprofit corporations at least in
New Hampshire are any organization
that's um organized under chapter 292
that's the the New Hampshire statute
that allows the formation of nonprofits
and you can form a nonprofit for
charitable purposes but you can per a
nonprofit for many other different um
purposes as well um that are not uh
included so um for example C4s um which
are the social welfare organizations um
c6s membership organizations things like
the the Elks Club those are all
nonprofits but they're not Charities um
and this because of the way this bill is
worded any other nonprofit organization
um any of those types of organizations
would be allowed to uh to would be
covered under this statute even if they
were not a charity as defined in 721
follow up follow up so so I'm I'm asking
you what words do you think we should
have in line one and and I'm not
entirely sure about for the
statutes will that I'm concerned that
that word charity is in there because
some of these things are are not
Charities and we could just say for
nonprofit corporations accept that I
know that the churches are not nonprofit
organizations so do you understand the
question yes thank you for the than you
for clarifying um so uh charity our
churches are nonprofits but they are not
Charities under the the state statute um
I believe uh and I'm not an expert in
this but I believe that the line one
would not ultimately show up in the the
chapter uh in or in in the um the law as
it's as it amends the rsas is that
corre up so and it's also in the title
of the should we change the title of the
bill well that's important I think
though um so as far as which
organizations are eligible to conduct
these auctions um I don't think that the
the word charity auction introduces any
confusion into which organizations are
eligible because the language below is
is pretty clear about who would be
allowed to do
this yes R Aly thank you on this
language uh line one and the title are
created by the
drafters it is exceedingly hard to get
the drafters to change something that is
totally ER
erroneous and this one is just slightly
erroneous
I'm I'm sorry what um represent me what
was your concern no it isn't a concern
it's that this is not a concern because
it's not we would have to go to alakus
and get him to talk to the drafter and
get him to change his language it's not
legal language in of the
bill it is the description by
OSS okay um representative
Ames oh no okay representative
Erie thank
you you mentioned those um entities that
are organized under 292 there are some
entities that do charitable work that
aren't organized under 292 because
they're
organized under the
IRS and there's a section I forget the
chck chapter and verse it says that if
you're federally
organized you don't have to be State
organized that's the state law as
well it's in the banking
code sure so um so 292 RSA chapter 292
is the statute that that creates The
Entity and the IRS grants tax exempt
status to existing entities so most uh
nonprofits are formed as a as a
corporation or as a another type of
entity you can be formed as
um some of the uh some of the
associations um are not formed as
corporations I was unfortunately
shanding that a little bit but there are
there are organizations that are um
unincorporated associations they're not
formed under 292 but they have an IRS
tax exempt
status so follow up
Sir would we the need to put in or
having an IRS tax exempt status in there
someplace
I I or would we be then requiring
everyone to become organized even though
their Charter says they can't become
organized I'm thinking of the fraternal
organizations yeah I I I think um thank
you for the question that might create
more confusion because churches are not
uh often they don't often get a tax
exempt status from the IRS they simply
can operate without it so that could
make it uh there some some Churches do
seek tax exempt status and receive it
some choose not to um and it's it's up
to the church whether to seek it so that
could creat some confusion about who's
eligible you follow up on that follow up
you're aware that every organization is
now required to file the
1099 or excuse me a u yeah an EIN they
have to obtain an EIN number and file a
tax return every year every
organization uh whether they're
religious or not so federal tax laws is
not my my specialty it's my
understanding that uh there are churches
who do not uh do not seek a tax
exemption from the IRS and so if that
would be the the basis for granting this
uh for uh allowing this um this
auctioning to to occur that it might
inadvertently exclude certain churches
that you that the legislation was
intending to allow um simply removing
the reference to to RSA 7 21 um I think
makes uh would be pretty clear about
who's eligible because it encompasses
charitable educational religious or
other nonprofit
organizations thank you representative
spillsbury
so again to to attempt to simplify and
clarify in the way that I
began
um the existing statute that we're
amending will sound very
familiar 311 B13
2 says any Resident member of a
charitable educational religious or
other nonprofit organization within the
state may conduct a charity auction
without a license for that
organization so really all we're trying
to do is saying say in addition to a
resident member also a
nonmember okay that's all we're trying
to do so any
departure from that same
phrasing just introduces confusion
because it the question why did the
legislature mean something different by
choosing different words so let's not go
there um I'm going to use the word wide
and narrow in the same sentence here I
think representative Ames accurately
said this has a relatively narrow
purpose but the phrasing in terms of the
organizations charitable educational
religious or other nonprofit is Broad
it's intended to be sweep
so I think all of the concerns regarding
the definition of church or fraternal
organizations and youits of Columbus and
so on are included in this broad phrase
any effort to further amend it actually
works against that purpose and and I
think that's why the introduction if of
the Senate Amendment became
confusing the Senate Amendment 721 2B
that's the statute that defines
charitable
organization so inclusion of that phrase
just seemed to reverse the idea of being
Broad and inclusive and go to narrow it
okay so I I hope I believe uh Mr Haley
has said everything that I agreed with
and uh confirms what I'm saying if we
just go back to the original as
introduced language all of this
confusion
disappears uh thank you for the question
yes that's that's my um as far as I am
concerned um removing the if eligible
under RSA 7212 be language um removes
confusion um for me and does not uh make
it uh unclear to me which organizations
would be eligible to
participate thank you um I'm just going
to take one more question I think we we
keep circling around and coming back to
the same conclusion at this point yes
represent
elberger thank you Mr chairman I am um
more confused now than I was at the
beginning um I have a real problem with
using the term charity
because
I I'm not sure what we're talking about
with Charity if educational institutions
or any other institution comes along
let's say a for-profit school that comes
along and says we are having a charity
auction and because it says educational
institution can be included in here um
to me that that the term charity is a
contradiction so uh at this point um
barring a last
minute Epiphany I'll be voting against
this thank
you uh represent Ames just a comment on
that the uh the only
organizations
that could
host an auction by
a non-licensed person under this
proposed change are nonprofits by the
text of this bill non-member individuals
hired by a charitable educational
religious or other nonprofit
organization um okay I want to wrap it
up representative PL you have something
to yes I'm going to ask representative
spillsbury
if we struck the word charity in uh uh
line one and then Below on line five
struck charity would affect anything I
represent PL I believe that um that is
not part of this uh bill that's
just a reference is that what is part of
this bill well I I can answer both those
okay the caption charity auctions I
think is just using a term of phrase in
common usage right and that's not the
statute what what what lines one and two
are saying is insert the next paragraph
right so the statute is lines uh 3 to 10
here right so uh represent elberger to
that point does that make it easier for
you to accept this where that's just
reference to where this is going to be
placed
and not you
know okay all right uh represent Ames
and then we will and I I probably
shouldn't open my mouth
um since we seem to be just about there
but in line five the the charity
auctions concept does reemerge and uh I
just want to point that out and say that
I think uh it it would be construed by
anyone who needed to construe this as
being as the word being used in its
uh in its sort of definitional sense
common definitional sense as a CH it's
it's not to uh make more money for the
organization that's uh hosting the
auction but it's to promote a charity or
charitable purpose that uh can be
defined it's some general concept but I
think it needs to be in there it's uh
you don't want to uh
allow um I I think the per the drafter
of this didn't have in mind allowing
auctions to be conducted by unlicensed
auctioneers that would uh raise money
for the business side of say a nonprofit
hospital um you know I think that's I
see that my friend down there has some
I'm also reluctant to open my mouth but
I agree completely with what
representative Ames just said and I
would point out that in the existing law
the exact same references made May
conduct a charity auction without a
license yeah there you go thank you
thank you all right thank you Mr Haley
appreciate your time thank
you and thank you also for coming on
very short notice uh as
well um at this point we need uh based
on the discussion we need an
amendment um and I think the consensus
is to remove online four if eligible
under RSA 721
Tob um so um while
um Jen is that something that you can
have drafted um while that's being done
I'm going to
um uh suspend I don't know what the
appropriate word is recess the exec
session and um
hold on recess the exec session and come
back uh after when the bill comes in
we'll we'll go into the public hearings
representative fellows yeah I would Ju
Just like to ask if it won't hold up the
process if we could work on the
title The the ACT title and change it to
Auctioneer license exemption for
nonprofits because this is really we're
we're talking about Auctioneer licenses
so that would just to make that more
clear I would rather not change the
title we can't change the title without
going through
alonis and him going to the drafter and
the drafter agreeing
to okay I think that the drafter if we
ask for it I as I said if it doesn't
hold it
up well we could pursue that I it it'll
it would hold it up um okay so I am now
going to
recess the um the exec session on SB
513 um and once that uh Amendment comes
through we will reopen the exec session
once whatever public hearing we're on is
finished um okay so that is recessed
thank you uh Mr Haley and thank you um
uh Al ay for being here appreciate
it do you have a
gav
okay okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on SB
representative Lang we now recognize you
Senator Lang thank you Mr chair thank
you members of the committee it's great
to be back in Ways and Means again um
Senator Tim Lang representative district
2 um I'm sure this feels like deja vu
all over again on this topic um this
bill before you is our historic horse
racing and moratorium bill um this time
we hold the moratorium at 7 years um
extending it out for a period of seven
years to give time for the industry to
mature to see what we want to do um it
also gives time for the charitable
gaming commission to do its work and
make recommendations to the committee
after reviewing the data and and what's
what's happening within the industry um
the bill is pretty straightforward again
um we add the people who have already
applied for licenses in a narrow window
of time uh to lienes we then extend the
moratorium out seven years a new wrinkle
to this bill is we've added uh Municipal
hosts to be able to act in essence as a
charity um but only if there are dates
available so the charity gets first bid
on the dates if there are dates still
available after all the Charities have
been serviced it would allow a
municipality to be able to hold up to 10
days and the revenue the 35% Revenue
that would normally go to a charity
would go to the municipality offset any
local costs um in addition to that um it
um it also restricts the transfer of
licenses um and I think it's just a
restatement of law um as you're all well
aware you can't sell gaming license in
New Hampshire you can sell the business
but not a license in and of itself
outside of the business so this restates
that and makes it clear that that is the
exact law happy to take questions thank
you uh represent
ery uh thank you uh Senator
Lang the question is New York put
similar restrictions on their taxi
medallions immediately the value of The
Medallion
Skyrock
won't the same thing happen with the
value of uh businesses that are engaged
in here and th thus restrict trade and
make this type of
activity um less competitive and more
expensive for the consumer so again
that's again why it's a seven-year uh
Sunset Clause it allows us to evaluate
what's going on in the industry and if
we choose to do nothing the moratorium
will expire and it'll become a
full-blown free market again um
however um at this point because it's a
pretty significant change in how gaming
operates uh this new form of gaming in
HHR um we think we need a slight pause
to see what's going on to make sure uh
the data supports any other changes we
make follow up and you're assuming that
Lottery is going to keep this data I'm
sorry say that question again you're
assuming that Lottery is going to
maintain a database that would provide
the
information uh regarding the cost of
licenses and the competitive
competitivness
competitiveness of the um business so
again so the charitable gaming
commission that we established uh last
year which is meeting now is one of the
topics we're reviewing is exactly that
we get the data on what the market can
support what the uh Revenue looks like
we're just we just hired I think the
executive Council last week hired the um
the uh people were bring in Spectrum
gaming the experts were bringing in who
are going to be doing modeling for New
Hampshire as compared to other states
and what that looks like but again we
don't have that data we will have that
data after that analysis is done thank
you sir representative
Southworth thank you for taking my
question could you provide a little more
context about the availability of the
dates because it seemed like at least in
some uh fac facilities they get used up
very quickly much more competitive so
I'm just wondering for example if there
often will even be anything available
for municipalities in some There Will
and some they won't um so to your point
in in the larger uh charitable Gaming
facilities those dates probably wouldn't
be available um and the smaller ones
they tend to be I I tell you that in the
bill when we had this conversation um we
had a charity come forward in the Senate
Ways and Means hearing um wi Arrow from
lonia um and they talked about there was
availability right away for dates um
through the Belmont uh gaming casino and
they went in they did the application
they were immediately given a date cuz
there were dates available so some of in
some cases there will be dates available
some cases there won't be so really it's
really variable correct thank you
represent alink thank you following up
on that one I think this is
totally impossible you are saying in
line8 that it is required that they
annually oper operate a minimum of seven
but not more than 10 game game dates for
the benefit of town or city required and
then you go on to say all of the times
when they don't want to do it but you've
said not withstanding any not provision
of
Law and I was under the impression that
just about nothing except the North
Country uh possibly Lebanon at this
point because there's this tiny little
place that's still operating while
they're waiting to build the Taj Mahal
uh on our very trafficked Road
um is um on has any game dates they've
got long waiting
lists so how does this work except for
maybe in Berlin and possibly
lonia again it's where it was available
uh understanding that not every
charitable gaming facility is going to
have dates I will also tell you that the
topic you're look you're talking about
relative to um uh Charities and gaming
operators again is under provision and
purview of the charitable gaming
commission they're looking at how those
Charities are selected how days are
selected um again that that commission
is is is looking at a lot of topics
rather with charitable gaming and how
you know we we've to a certain extent
we've kind of patch this law as we've
gone along and not taken a big picture
look um and so uh I would I'll just say
to you again the same as I said to
represent Southworth it's going to be ad
hoc it's going to be sometimes it will
be sometimes there won't be there could
be a charity that was a lotted games
that all of a sudden on a Tuesday went
out of business and now there's a hole
in the schedule and they get a lot that
time to a town I I I don't know all the
conditions and circumstances that a town
would be able to get dates other than to
say that if there's a hole in the
schedule they would be able to plug it
with the town to be able to use that as
a a a a
source
and and the gaming commission is looking
at how Charities are selected and what
that looks like representative Aly I've
this is just a follow up I do have
another question later on one you say
required not withstanding any provision
of law to the
contrary and two there's no uh nothing
in here about on what if the town
doesn't want any of this and didn't want
it in the first place like Littleton and
like
Lebanon um but has been forced to take
it thank you that hadn't come up in any
of the hearings I talked about a town
was going to refuse Revenue um I hadn't
heard that conversation anywhere else I
I suppose if you want to amend it to
allow an opt out of the Town say we're
don't want your money you can do
that representative PL describe to me
the horribles that might happen if we if
we eliminate the
moratorium so again I I I wouldn't
presume to you mean to make it free
market as it is right now again I
wouldn't presume to make that guess that
Chad gaming commission is working on
that um
the the concern was again a
proliferation um right now I think I
don't know in the most current number
the last time I heard about 1,800
machines in New Hampshire so far um for
HHR um the the question is whether what
the proliferation would look like if we
had an unrestricted Market again that's
part of the chatable Gaming's uh review
with uh Spectrum gaming the experts in
the field to make that determination for
us before we start making
changes uh represent fellows um thank
you can you remind me of when the change
was made to say that it could be two
Charities on the same date was that just
last year or so that was Again part of
the original HHR bill which I can't
remember I think it was representative
duet's bill um or AB abrami I can't
remember which it was um that did that
bill that allowed for two uh charities
in a given night one for games of chance
and one for the
HHR repres Aly did you have a question
oh yes I I did have another question I
just I hadn't realized that one of them
would only be the machines and one of
them would only be the tables but
um I I did want to
just ask
again why we bother to put in transfer
or sale of license prohibited when the
businesses are already there there are
at least four in the group that Lebanon
is in that are owned by the same outside
of the state companies working through a
developer in
Manchester and there I think are the two
in in uh
nashwa are also owned by the same person
yes and probably with people from
outside the state controlling that one
uh so it's really hard to think that
this is any kind of a free market
and I gather that the Lottery Commission
does not think that um that a light a um
business can be kept from merging with
another in any way at any time so thank
you for the question again if I
understand that this is a restatement of
law that says that the license itself
cannot be sold outside the business so I
can't remember I I form a business I
apply for a gaming a charitable gaming
license and then I apply for an HHR
license right those two licenses are
assets of the business they can't be
sold separately from the business that's
just a restatement of law that makes it
clear that that's what we intend is that
the license itself I can't sell the HHR
license outside of selling my whole
business and I can't sell my charitable
gaming license outside of selling my
whole
business could I just ask yeah
does this I don't remember the law being
any different before this so does this
change whatever it was um actually
create any further impediment to us
being all owned by Las
Vegas so again um represent M me to my
point you can always sell a business and
I don't think we want to restrict the
sale of businesses in the state of New
Hampshire because they're just llc's and
you would have to good luck trying to
figure that out out um this says you
can't sell the license in and of itself
so I can sell my business and if my
business has assets the assets go with
that
business does this change what is the
change in the existing language again I
think it takes what's in currently in
rules and puts it into law oh um we've
always had the idea that you could never
sell a license um and this just puts it
into statute that clarifies and restates
you cannot sell your license it makes it
absolutely clear representative duet
that was oh
okay yes represent elberger thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh licensed Charities yeah I
know I can do this you have trouble uh
licensed
Charities um are I assume uh Charities
that are under
501c but the following numbers are not
restricted well actually they are and
that's in the charitable gaming statute
like um um so there are there are
Provisions what what qualifies and what
doesn't and that's in the um gaming
statute now is that a similar list to
the list that we were talking about in
the last bill I'm not sure I don't think
so because again that was talking more
about not for-profits for charitable
purposes and not necessarily charitable
charitable operations so um I will say
just to take a divers that section about
that RSA and that bill was added at
Senator Rosa Wall's request um she asked
she wanted a bill and I just agreed to
it so you strike it I have no problem
with that it wasn't in the original Bill
follow follow up thank you um I'm
curious as to why um we have Charities
given preference over
municipalities again that was a
negotiated agreement in the Senate uh
with our Democratic colleagues and our
Republican colleagues um the Charities
didn't want to see lost Revenue so again
if we for
if we forced or or if we said that
municipalities were treated exactly the
same but there was a shall in there
saying every year they get 7 to 10 days
um then there's a charity gets displaced
and that causes some consternation in
our group um in the Senate Ways and
Means so we wanted to make sure that no
charities got displaced by the
municipality one more very um I'm not
sure this is a question but more of a
statement if we look at a charity as an
organiz ganization that provides for the
public good without a financial benefit
for
shareholders I don't see a definition a
distinction between a charity and a
municipality I agree thank you represent
fellows thank you um last year we had
some questions about the fairness of how
the Charities were selected and the fact
that when they get in the door you know
they get to stay there usually and it's
the operators that of the um
establishment that select who they are
do we what is the status of that do we
have a study commission looking at that
or is
are oh I'm sorry there are there any
bills related to that so again the
charal gaming commission is looking at
that um to make recommendations on any
future possible legislation if it's
necessary representative
Ames um
just uh further on the ownership and the
transfer question that representative
Aly was asking um I think it would you
agree that uh it would be possible for
the state to set a a rule
in uh legislation that even the
charitable gaming commission might
recommend that would um uh preclude sort
of monopolization of all the um
operating historic horse racing
charitable gaming sites by one entity
you could you could uh limit and uh
limit
owners you could spread out the
ownership I we could figure out a way to
do that um that would not
preclude a owner of a
particular uh one of these Enterprises
from selling it but they just couldn't
sell it to another casino operator in
the state so that you would avoid this
monopolization issue that I think
representative Aly is concerned
about so I guess my answer is yes having
served four terms in the house three
terms in the house and one in the Senate
the legislature can do anything it
wants including allowing short tail
monkeys for
pets all right representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chair Senator Lang I
perhaps you can uh clarify for us what
was the effect of the amendment adopted
by the Senate relative to its original
Bill thank you so it was the addition of
the municipal hosts um was a was the big
part I I think we also my original bill
was a four-year and we negotiated to a 7
year to get everybody on board okay I
wondered about that looking at the
fiscal note where it refers to four
years so it was originally introduced as
2028 and it was amended to 2031 correct
thank
you represent om thank you on do you why
do you not want to take the uh position
that was sent to you from the house
which we thought would have a better
chance of getting through the
governor I'm I'm assuming you're talking
about Senate Bill 112 and I'm not to
discuss that right
now why do you think that the governor
is more likely to take this one so again
you're talking about Senate Bill 112 and
I'm not ready to discuss that right now
no I'm talking about this
one I'm sorry so your questions why do I
think why would the governor sign this
one when he's refused to sign I wouldn't
presume to speak with the governor but I
had had conversations with the governor
and it seems to be he's in a favorable
position to this
bill
thank you Senator seeing no more
questions okay um next up I have uh Rick
Newman thank you Mr chairman uh my name
is Rick Newman I'm representing the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association we are in support of Senate
Bill
472 I wanted to uh start by uh trying to
answer a couple of questions that have
been asked um section three which is the
section that prohibits the sale of the
license is in fact simply a restatement
of the current law in the current law
that sentence exists
in Roman
2 this bill has redrafted Roman 2 so it
removed that sentence from Roman 2 and
it gives it its own paragraph So it's a
new paragraph 8 but that sentence is in
and has been in current law for many
years it is pretty well settled across
the country and I think probably across
the world that uh in the gaming business
you can't sell a license so uh I can by
an entity that may be eligible for a
license but then I have to go and prove
my own worth be vetted by the uh author
licensing Authority which in this case
is the Lottery Commission so I just
wanted I wanted to address
that in our view the most important part
of this bill is section s which is the
section that extends the moratorium date
out to
2031 and as you folks I'm sure well
aware this is at least the fourth time
you've seen a bill to extend uh that U
limitation or moratorium whatever you
want to call it uh you've passed Senate
Bill 51 which was vetoed by the governor
uh you've passed Senate Bill 112 which
would have made the moratorium
indefinite that's uh in the Senate has
yet to be acted on you passed the
representative duet's bill which again I
I think I forget the number but it it
also made the uh moratorium uh
indefinite and um and here we are
addressing that issue again in My View
From what I understand this is the bill
that has a chance of becoming law so if
we're going to otherwise what happens in
July 1 of 24 and the question was asked
what would be the downside to that well
in July 1 of
2024 unlimited entities could
uh apply for historic horse racing
licenses and at the moment you might U
while we have uh 14 Gaming facilities
and I believe 10 of them have historic
horse racing uh We Believe As game
operators that that's enough and the
market can't really take much more than
that this bill is going to allow up to
five other potential new
facilities but we don't think anybody
really wants to see a state with 50 or
100 locations and I believe that's a
very real possibility so uh we think
extending the moratorium is very
important uh and I just want to address
the host Community sections five and six
where that addresses where the
potentially where the money goes where
the money goes is not our concern that's
yours um we uh we are um you know happy
to have some of it go to a host
Community if that is the if it works out
in in as Senator Lang said it wouldn't
probably happen in every location
because many places have a waiting list
uh but those that don't could use this
provision to uh get money for the host
Community um I would point out
that given the fact that this bill will
increase by some number up to five uh
the number of facilities that will
likely be operating uh if this bill
passes uh just keep in mind that for
each facility that's that opens that's
730 new charity gaming dates that become
available so if a host Community got 10
days from each and every room that's
only 140 gaming dates and if one new
entity opens you're going to add 7:30 to
the inventory so I don't see any you
know really diminishing
Charity's uh Revenue here um
with that I'll take questions if you
have it representative
PL I'm
confused if I find the right line
now uh not with uh under uh page two
line 7 um not withstanding any
provisional law to the contrary game
operat employees licensed under RSA 287
D4 required to in operate minimum of
seven but not more than 10 game dates
for the benefit of town or city Etc
that's required and yet I hear from
Senator Lang that this is after
Charities if there dates available I'm
confused it uh how how does this what
does this required mean do they have to
bump Charities off to do it well I
believe I I I understand what you're
saying representative and keep in mind
we didn't participate in the drafting of
this language this is not our this isn't
our thing but I do believe that uh
section six uh
addresses that and says if there are
Charities available the municipality
does not get uh any of those
days representative jet thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question Mr
Newman um just for reference if if these
uh applicants that were in the queue
right now were to secure the licensees
you said
uh it would add somewhere in the
neighborhood of about 700 plus Charities
to the pool that would be eligible 730
game dates yes right the dates um do you
have any idea as to with the present
operators how many PE how many Charities
are in the weit lists or how many
Charities are in the queue to and this
is in relation to the charal gaming
commission too it's kind of information
that would be interesting specific to
this municipality compon my my latest
information excuse me my latest
information is that uh I believe all of
the rooms have a waiting list for
Charities um I'm not aware of any that
have Open dates follow up okay thank you
um and you don't a charity doesn't have
to be specific to that Community to that
specific Community say Salem Little
League Baseball can have a and I just
happen to know this have dates in
Manchester correct right so any any uh
qualified charity can be in any
charitable gaming room that's correct
and I would just point out that that was
really made possible by changes you
folks made a few years ago when you
eliminated the requirement that a
charity representative had to be at the
facility that opened the it up to so
that a place in a charity located in
Berlin could have game dates in
Manchester more of a statement because I
know it's not the operator's position um
but we as a legislature went through a
series of years where we were trying to
legalize Casino gaming in New Hampshire
and my town Salem was a focus of that to
me reading this and specifically the
requet language and and on and on to me
charitable gaming Services charities
Charities that need Service delivery to
our communities and and we're all aware
of that this is a slippery slope writing
in town and I understand the benefit to
the towns and
municipalities but this legislature
chose the charity model to go forward
and I don't want to in any way shape or
form negate Service delivery to the many
eligible uh Charities that do great work
for our
constituents under the guise of a little
sugar cube for a town and municipality
for for hosting a charitable gaming room
so I just think we have a charitable
gaming model it needs to stay with the
Charities it if I could just address
that
briefly excuse
me I'm not going to say I disagree with
anything that you said representative
duet but I will say this I have I am
greatly concerned about this issue of
the moratorium and uh you know as we
know as the legislative process proceeds
and goes forward um we get into if we
have to get into a situation whether
there's a conference committee or
something like that I'm concerned about
the moror I think the uh the urgency of
extending the moratorium uh supersedes
any other concerns particularly
since and I can follow up with my
members to confirm this but I believe I
can represent without fear of
contradiction to you that uh at least as
of today every room has a waiting list
for
Charities representative
ER representing the Charities you're
aware of whatever or what happens in
other
states yes are are you aware of any
jurisdictions where this type of legisl
exists I'm not we're we really are
unique in New Hampshire in every other
of the what is it 38 loc uh
jurisdictions I believe in the country
that offer casino gambling it's all
commercial gambling that doesn't mean
there isn't Bingo or other types of
Charity gaming that take place in those
other states there certainly are but our
casino gambling in in New Hampshire is
focused on charity gaming and there is
no other other state that does anything
like
that thank you okay thank you seeing no
more questions thank you thank you Mr
chairman next I have uh
Alysa maral
margin thank you chairman janigian um
members of the committee for the record
my name is Alyssa marglin I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Center
for nonprofits
we're the Statewide Association of New
Hampshire's nonprofit sector um we do
not have a position on the moratorium
I'm here to speak uh and raise concerns
about
um uh shifting revenue from uh the
charitable sector to the host community
and also um uh issues around how um
Charities are selected so again we don't
have a position on the moratorium and as
you've just had a good exchange you know
we have um gaming in New Hampshire to
the extent that we license a sponsoring
charity and those Charities include C3
C4 C7 C8 C10 c19 according to our gaming
statutes so we license those entities
that sponsor operators who provide these
activities for the public um and that
has um brought in really essential
Revenue to the nonprofit sector and in
New Hampshire the um we rely on the
nonprofit sector more than other states
uh providing essential services to our
communities um this of course lowers tax
burdens overall because uh we have fewer
government contracts and we're able to
identify philanthropic and other sources
of revenue for the charitable sector I
do want to thank chairman Lang and the
members of his committee when we express
concerns about the proposal to shift
dates that were currently available to
the Charities uh to the host community
that we were opening the door to a
slippery slope as we know in New
Hampshire there are many needs uh don't
doubt that there are um impacts and
costs that happen at the municipal level
and we do recognize that um uh all the
effort and infrastructure that goes into
make these activities that happen that
generate this revenue and his committee
did provide a thoughtful amendment that
essentially gives the right a first
refusal or however you want to look at
it that says if you have a wait list and
you have charities in line that you
wouldn't provide those dates to host
communities um we we ask this committee
to consider if there may be other
another source uh that makes more sense
to address some of the needs because
really the although the revenue
generated for a charity is Meaningful
for their bottom line so for example one
of our members provides shelter beds uh
for domestic violence boys and girls
clubs provide extra after school um
activities and can provide uh capacity
for that but whether or not this is
really going to C provide for the law
enforcement needs or whatever the the
local needs are we're not sure that that
Revenue here really makes sense but we
do appreciate um the effort and the
understanding and that we were heard in
the Senate but I do want to say that for
us um on page two section six lines
essentially 255 through 27 this was
extra language that was added to the
amendment that
says shall not apply if the facility
lensey institutes a policy for bidding
the facility from hosting a specific
charity or specific type of Charity due
to Prior conflicts with Charity
management or employees we're not aware
of any history of kind of problematic
relationships between the sponsoring
charity and the management we're not
really sure what the enforcement
mechanism would be for this we are
concerned about um issues Around Mission
bias and other things that could come
into play so ask that you consider
striking that if you decide to keep uh
the amendment um with that that really
uh concludes um our our testimony and
our our view of this proposal I'm happy
to take any questions thank
you thank
you represent no any question yeses pres
elberger thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question one of the things
you pointed out is that New Hampshire is
heavily dependent on charitable
organizations to provide
services and uh that cities and towns
are not able
to if there were funding for cities and
towns to provide the services that
Charities are picking
up how would you then feel
about um giving municipalities the same
access to those charitable
dates my understanding is that this
proposal would not translate into a
nonprofit grant program at the municipal
level or
enhanced services for vulnerable
populations or other things but I mean
again we um our our nonprofits are kind
of local Partners everywhere um New
Hampshire Center for nonprofits spends a
lot of time teaching good management and
stewardship and best practices and
obviously nonprofit sector is open more
to public scrutiny of Revenue and
spending um and so we don't uh we don't
want to keep municipalities from uh
raising the revenue needed to uh host
gaming in their Community we just don't
think that gaming days from the
Charities is the way to do it um but you
know we do understand that overall an
expansion of Gaming could be an
expansion of Revenue days for for
Charities uh and it is a complex issue
um and so we understand that you know
there compromises needed and and give
and take uh but in this case we don't
feel like we are really solving
Municipal needs and um we're potentially
opening up a slippery slope pulling
money away from Charities followup
followup thank you my
question is if municipalities were given
the funding that they
needed which might include some funding
through charitable organizations that
that is currently limited to uh
charitable organizations through these
through the
casinos would the need for charitable
organizations to pick up those Services
which municipalities may not be able to
afford because some of their revenue is
being lost and quite frankly not being
provided by the
state would you be looking at this
differently
um and your comment about uh
transparency in in terms municipalities
are probably the
most
uh
monitored but but I'm wondering if
municipalities were getting some of the
funding that's now being moved into
charitable organizations and we're
actually able to provide the services
that belong to the municipalities to
provide how so I think I understand
representative elberg are you saying if
more Revenue was provided to host
municipalities would that translate into
more services for the public good
lessening the need for the charitable
sector is that your question so that is
not our experience for example pandemic
related resources that came to many
municipalities um uh did not translate
into the municipalities taking on
delivering those services and in limited
cases where that happened they have
pulled back so for example in the city
of Manchester right now you know the the
incoming mayor who's very dedicated to
addressing the issues around
homelessness has pulled back on
Municipal support for the shelter saying
that this needs to be run by the by the
nonprofit community so I mean we um
we're again it's always in Partnership
and there are there's County resources
there are municipal resources and
federal resources that flow through
Title One communities that go to the
charitable sector but in general I don't
think that this would take care of this
would not supplant the public good that
the charitable sector is doing but I
appreciate the thought in the
question um I had a question over here
representative elme and then
representative PL yes have you thought
of the fact that there is such a huge
profit that we are getting large numbers
of outside of New Hampshire um takeovers
going on on that on the model that was
used could be manipulated instead to use
part of that profit for municipalities
instead of taking it from the
charities
um was that a question or more
rhetorical ones representative
which okay all right and that may be
something we can talk about in a work
session as well uh yes representative
lefley oh I'm sorry I already told
representative PL and then
representative leing thank you this may
be an obvious question but Charities
must like the moratoriums too because
the ones who get the dates get get
better Revenue than if there were 50
100 um again the center for nonprofits
doesn't have a position on the
moratorium um there is I don't think any
competitive benefit uh to it either way
in fact you know having more gaming
dates would would make more Revenue
available I do just for the um education
of of all of us overall um you know
Revenue has gone up the legislature has
allowed you know uh wage levels and um
to to increase um and so Wagers to
increase rather so uh however the
percentage that's going to the chable
sector has decreased significantly so
while the revenue in the space has grown
and the overall dollar amount to the
sector has grown Charities now take uh
10% less of the revenue um and that's
likely to uh continue uh because of the
increase in
HHR um
and just the profitability of the
activity representative
leapley thank you Mr chair um are you
aware of any negative impacts of
gambling on host
communities I I can't speak for the um
from the perspective of um you know the
municipal Association or or any any
adverse impacts to what local
municipalities are dealing with thank
you thank you um
thank you
um I too am concerned about the fact
that the percentage that's going to
Charities is going down um so I think
that's something we need to keep in mind
um I think we also need to take a step
back and make sure we're looking at the
big picture of what gambling is supposed
to be doing in our state like why we
allow this in the first place and why we
are supposed to oversee it so I think
your point about the chair ities is is
well taken that it's supposed to be um
going there and we know that a much
bigger percentage is going to the game
operators many of whom are outside of
New Hampshire and so this could be a
siphon increasingly of money leaving New
Hampshire instead of enriching um
nonprofits which it's was designed to do
so I think we need to think about the
big picture of this I also am um
saddened about your I come from
represenative is there a question there
do you have a question for
her um yes I do have a question okay if
I ask please ask the question
um I'm concerned about your comments
about Manchester it
um I wonder if you feel that the
Partnerships with the cities um are
declining because it seems to me
that the the philosophy of this is we
don't have to raise taxes we can provide
funds to Charities they'll provide the
public services that used to be provided
by the state or the city and so
therefore we won't have to raise taxes
do you feel that your relationship with
the cities is declining because of this
concept of the Cities don't have any
money to provide public services that is
for the charities to do and so we the
city as you cited in Manchester aren't
going to do that work because we don't
have the money it's not our job it's the
Charity's job do you feel like that has
changed recently I mean overall I can't
really cite examples of a declining
relationship I if if the pandemic has
taught us anything about the charitable
sector is that nonprofits are essential
and that they are incredibly Nimble um
and I think that our um most productive
uh Community oriented nonprofits have
managed to work with every
Administration from every party in many
different fiscal challenges highs and
lows um and uh for the most part I do
think it's a a very solid foundation my
point was simply um responding to
representative elberger if I thought
that more Revenue headed towards
municipalities would supplant the need
for the charitable sector was no but
generally I I don't feel that there's
any kind of relational decline between
our you know we're where uh we have our
Municipal sector we have our nonprofit
sector we have our private sector and
when they're all working together um you
know I think it's uh good outcomes for
granite Staters thank you thank you
thank you all right thank you thank you
very much thank you all right that's all
I have for pink cards is there anyone
else who would like to testify testify
on S SP
yes
still morning good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Katherine Heck from
The New Hampshire Municipal Association
and I did not prepare testimony but I
did want to make sure that we expressed
that we are neutral on this bill and
while that might seem a bit surprising
as we do come to you regularly looking
for state aid and partnership with the
state on a number of issues in this
particular case we do not take positions
on bills that could potentially pit
municipality against municipality where
some currently might have gaming and
others might not have that option this
would be a legislative decision um that
we will not be weighing in on as to
whether or not you allow cities and
towns to have um some portion of the
charitable gaming I will say that we do
enjoy our 234 cities and towns very very
healthy and important relationships with
our nonprofits who provide services a a
a huge range of services Statewide to
our residents and our municipalities do
enjoy working with our nonprofits to
fill those holes that the government
cannot fill so we do find our nonprofit
sector to be critical to be critical to
our residents and I just didn't want to
think that there was um it if there's
some individual tensions going on or in
some area um that is not something that
we're getting a lot of feedback on as we
know that our members really do work
with their nonprofit partners and they
are really critical in our communities
as they do respond quickly and nimbly
and flexibly to things that government
might not be able to do so if you have
any questions I'm happy to take them I
just wanted our neutral position on the
record thank you representative PL uh
because I don't have a kink pink cired
in front of me I'm when I ask you to
spell your last name oh yes sir heck h c
k like what the heck H
C okay and I will get you a pink card
sir thank you yes representative
leapley thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question um so I understand
that you don't want to weigh in on
something where it might be competitive
between different municipalities because
of their relationship with gaming um I'm
wondering if uh the association is aware
or is municipalities have expressed any
concerns about gaming um that it's been
a negative impact uh or cost them money
that they've needed to invest in you
know maybe gaming addiction has
increased or anything like that thank
you so I have not heard of anything
around gaming addiction specifically I
do know that with any business that
brings in visitors any business at all
we we do see an increase in perhaps our
Public Services like police fire for for
that for example and I do know the
Senate was trying to address that influx
into a community around gaming in their
Amendment um I will say that a charity
that I'm involved in locally in my
little Community was able to get a space
after two years um it's our meeting
house restoration committee for our town
and we got on the charitable gaming list
um in lonia I believe and we live in by
Peterboro and Greenfield so far away and
we got $155,000 from our our two- we
stint so again I think that depending on
the facility the the the amount of time
I'm I can't speak to the financial what
each town would receive because that is
a question that has been asked of us and
I can't speak to that because I think it
depends on the receipts of that casino
in that time period um so I think it
really is very dependent as I know other
communities have received $60,000 for
their charity um in that same period at
a different location representative PL
um yes is you say there may be some
increase police and fire and so on what
what is the property tax revenue for uh
CH for gaming establishments compared to
any other commercial property well it's
assessed certainly the same way as any
other other property we have to be fair
reasonable and proportionate so it's
assessed the same way as any other
commercial space and again I'm not
picking on on our Gaming facilities and
saying that they do create or don't
create there's a many industries that
bring an influx of people in because
they're places that visitors would like
to um come and see which is positive for
our communities as well thank you
representative fellows uh thank you um
does your organization have a position
on um
municipalities um ability to say yes or
no to having um a Casino in their
community and CU I think we have a bill
related to that but I don't think it's
I'm I'm not sure the status of
that so just generally I won't speak
about other legislation in this hearing
but we always defer to the position of
local control and having the ability to
opt in and being able to plan and Zone
um accordingly so that it's um can be
successful for everybody involved so the
local option is always our deferred
preference follow up so so they so they
don't have that ability right
now I will have to get back to you I I
believe that local zoning and there are
certain considerations but I will have
to get back to with a more detailed
answer thank you I'm seeing no more
questions thank you very much than you
very much for your
time
okay I will now close the public hearing
on Mr chairman before you close yeah I
have a question for lottery okay um can
we invite Lottery
up good morning John coni uh Chief
compliance officer for the New Hampshire
Lottery Commission uh last name is co n
f
RTI and I will get a pin card in happy
to answer any questions thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking this
question
um it says a total of five entities I'm
reading the methodology on the back of
the financial
note speaks about the the total of five
entities applied for a game operator and
then your last page the Lottery
Commission States it cannot assess the
final impact of this because it is
unclear how many of the five additional
applicants will be found suitable for
charitable gaming and squally seek a
license to offer
HHR is there a theoretical
mathematical way for you to just give
estimates so I there there there isn't
really um so the the all we can tell you
is that with regard to the language as
it sits right now that open that second
window from January 1 to October 18
of
2023 that there are five entities that
fit within that window um they're in
various States within their application
status licensing status and we can't
speak about that um so each one will be
vetted um and so we can't really address
today whether zero through five of those
will actually be licensed at the end of
that
process thank yeah representative
Aly uh thank you this is for the chair
yes um I assume we'll be planning for a
work session yes and it would be helpful
at least for me to be really clear about
if there a waiting list for every place
because it seems to me if there are
waiting lists for every place it does
really affect parts of the bill that
means they'll be nothing for
municipalities and maybe nothing for any
new Charities and I think that really
puts this bill in a different context if
we already have these waiting lists so
I'd appreciate that thank
you okay uh represent
El is there well we are apparently not
allowed to know anything about how much
profit there is in this
business
uh and but on I just wanted your take on
that um so representative Aly we do very
extensive Revenue reporting um on how
much revenue is taken in from each
Casino for each uh uh activity um and
obviously how much goes to each charity
and how much goes to the state and that
is all posted on our website so um
there's a um tremendous amount of
visibility into the economics um
certainly um um we don't have all of the
overhead costs that are associated with
operating um uh we we do a review uh
during licensing to make sure that the
um finances of the uh applicant or the
lcy are uh sustainable um but certainly
I think that there is visibility into
what
into uh the revenue generation out of
these facilities um and I think um given
some other information that uh certainly
the study committee has done um they've
they've gotten some testimony on some of
the costs that go into um operation of
the
facility so get that clear on we can't
know the gross but we can know the net
after they've taken all of their
expenses including outside the
state the only thing that we don't have
complete visibility into is there
everyday operating costs or overhead um
so we certainly do understand some of
the the the the elements of that for
example um we're aware uh as an industry
that an HHR machine um if it's being
leased um that can cost 20% of the gross
Gaming revenue around around that number
it can be a little more a little less
depending on the specific game um
obviously there's labor cost there's
electric cost those types of things
that's not something that the state
collects on a regular basis because it
doesn't have an impact on either the
Charity's revenue or the state's Revenue
so in terms of uh I think what your
question is asking in terms of their net
profitability we don't have complete
insight into all overhead costs in these
build in these uh facilities um but
certainly I would say that there's a
there's a lot of information available
about um about
the revenue that flows through these
facilities representative fellows thank
you um I'm interested in the money
that's available from a from take one
Casino so the money that's available to
them probably it is divided into two
parts because one charity during a
certain night one charity is getting
money from the the slot machines and the
other one is getting money from the
table games
and I know that not all the casinos have
the slot machines so I I'm just
interested in the disparity so so if you
have if if we have a municipality and a
charity saving um on one night it
matters which part you're going to get
the money from anything you can share
about that yeah s f fellows thank you
for uh for the question because that was
um I just want to clarify something
there was that was divided in terms of
one one entity got HHR one entity got
table games that actually was sunset and
now it is an even split between all
revenues so when two Charities come in
um to a uh a facility um charity a and
Charity B end up both splitting the HHR
and go Revenue equally um with respect
to and just one other just fine point
just for your understanding in
facilities and there's only a few at
this point that operate without HHR
machines they do not have to operate
with two Charities they only have to
operate with one and they choose to
usually only operate with one so there
is not that issue of U dividing up in
those
facilities
okay thank you actually I've got one
question so uh representative Southworth
asked if we can find out if there's
waiting lists for all Charities is is
that something that you can get an
answer for uh so Mr chairman I know um
uh Mr Newman indicated that we are um on
behalf of the study committee um getting
uh information from uh Charities and we
took a survey of Charities within the
state I think we have three or 400 um
respondents so we should have some data
on uh what charity experience is in
terms of getting um getting onto weight
lists or getting game dates um so
certainly we should have that I think in
advance of a work session okay thank
you thank you very
much okay with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on S SP
472 recognize me
first7
okay
okay what are we on
5977 all right so here are
these who's introducing it
l where's
okay we will open the uh public hearing
on SB 597 and uh recognize Senator Lang
thank you uh Mr chairman on behalf of
Senator aard I want to introduce Senate
Bill 597 Rel of the lucky s uh ticket
dispensary devices this bill is pretty
straightforward um current under current
law any machine we have that's done in a
social club or or a Lucky 7 machine has
to be able to print paper tickets
however across the country that is no
longer the standard and it's becoming
harder and harder for these
organizations to be able to get Lucky
Seven tickets so we just do away with
the requirement um or even the option
that the machine must be able to print a
paper
ticket that's the whole Bill thank you
any questions representative
PL no no question but I got handed
signature list request for removal or
requirement for pull tab printers for
electric Lucky 7
devices uh I won't read the entire
language but essentially is a support of
the bill and I by quick count it was 54
uh a game operators supporting the Bill
thank
you thank you any questions for Senator
um represent elme yeah just one on the
reason I always opposed this was that it
slowed down the game so that it wasn't a
slot machine how much faster or is it
without this put that with you uh again
I I don't have an answer to that direct
question again the answer in the Senate
ways the Means Committee when his bill
was heard one of the key components was
the fact that the machine's becoming
harder to find um without a paper
because um if you can display it on the
screen having that option the print uh
is is a rarely taken and B the machines
are getting harder to
find
yeah excuse me Mr chair I don't was this
introduced another day I wasn't given a
copy of this today uh 597 yes we got it
on a different day okay are there there
may be copies on the
table it's copies there's probably
copies on the table over
there does anyone else have question uh
repres Aly did you have a follow okay
just I would like to hear from Valerie
King she looked like she understood the
question all right um thank you Senator
Lang um uh Valerie king um if you
would come up to the
desk did you have an answer to that
question yeah could I just restate it on
are you going to be looking at these new
machines and how close they are to slot
Ma machines or to the HRM machines thank
you so good morning my name is Valerie
King with New Hampshire lottery um just
uh one of your questions was regard to
how fast it would if if not having paper
would speed it up I believe our rules it
would be based on our rules and I
believe they require that no that
there's at least a 3 to 5c delay between
each um before you can hit the button
again so having no paper won't change
that
um as far as the difference between a
Lucky 7 ticket dispenser and HHR and
slot machines it's a Lucky 7 is based on
a defined deal there's only so many
winners and losers in a deal which is
different than HHR which is based on a
paramutual wager or slot machines which
is based on a random number generator so
while they all have uh video displays
they the internal of how those wins or
losses are determined are
different thank
you okay um next I have Rick
Newman thank you Mr chairman my name is
Rick Newman I'm representing Grover
gaming which is a manufacturer of Lucky
7 machines that operated in New
Hampshire I'll be very brief I just I I
wanted to point out to the committee
that there was a time when the printing
of a ticket was required by state law in
these electronic lucky s
dispensers you folks made that optional
few years
back I can tell you that one facility
for instance that I'm aware of that had
about 50 of these devices would
literally throw away eight nine 10 big
green garbage bags of tickets every day
when they were required to be printed CU
customers you know the machine printed
it but the customer never looked at the
ticket because the display is on the
screen I can also tell you that since
you've made it optional there hasn't
been a roll of paper changed in any
machine that I'm aware of in the entire
State customers are not taking the
option so you might say well why do we
care then about it and the issue is
simply one of um ease of operation the
fact that a printer has to be connected
can sometimes cause the machine to
malfunction or the printer has to be
addressed and then it shuts the machine
down and it's really for nothing because
people just don't print the ticket
anymore so I think um the evolution of
these machines is at a point where we've
proven that the printing of a ticket is
not necessary we'd ask you to support
the
Bill thank you yes representative
fellows thank you um I was under the
impression from testimony I heard I
think last year that these tickets were
sometimes sold by at
campgrounds and are they using video
machines at campgrounds uh Lucky Seven
tickets come in two forms one is
electronic which is what this bill
addresses the other is a break open uh
you typical ticket you used to see
before machines existed um I would
assume if campgrounds are are selling
them they would be using the paper
breake open ticket I'm not aware of any
facility like that that has the
electronic dispenser
devices
okay follow up so so this eliminates the
paper option eliminates the paper option
only in the electronic
dispensing oh okay device okay okay the
the paper ticket itself is
still very much alive and
well okay great thank you very much
thank you Mr
chair okay last pink ticket I have is uh
Ashley CH
menis that's correct
wow thank you very much that was
perfect good morning everybody um good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Ashley I CH
Manis I represent Grover gaming in the
state of New Hampshire um and in 2021
the regulation that required that the
electronic uh machines print a
representation of the outcome of every
ticket played on an electronic device
was amended and the requirement that the
printed representation of the outcome of
that ticket played was adjusted from
being every time a ticket was played on
the electronic device to optional for
the player to print a ticket if they so
choose and since that adjustment was
made virtually no player chooses to
print that piece of paper which is um
something that I had presented to the
committee they we have a uh an agreement
not an agreement we have um some
documentation that states that are
fraternal and Veteran charity Partners
do not have any players that print those
those uh options out
um
so when they were required to print
after every ticket played we were
changing the very large roles of paper
that Mr Newman spoke of um multiple
times a week and in some cases uh per
month um but
the the issue with this is that millions
of very small pole tabs that represented
wins or losses on these devices were
just being thrown out and they had been
doing that for years um since the change
we have not replaced a single roll of
paper in any active device in the field
and many of these devices have been in
some of these organizations for uh
years um since the electronic Lucky 7s
still have the requirement that the
printed ticket be optional for the
player this can can lead to problems
with the machines themselves because if
a if a printer that creates this ticket
malfunctions in any way it puts that
machine out of operation until it's
fixed um so until a problem is is
resolved that machine cannot be played
which does not bring in revenue for
those charitable
organizations um all plays on any
electronic device are electronically
recorded So the paper representations
are not necessarily needed for any kind
of security reason um our machines
specifically also store 200 screenshots
of every of the last 200 tickets that
were played so um there is a visual
representation on the screen of the last
plays
um the requirement to have the
electronic pole tab
machines uh print this ticket um has no
benefit to our charitable Partnerships
um those organizations and and it
provides a disservice whenever those uh
printers are causing the machine to be
out of
operation so I would like to add that of
the six states that our uh company
represents similar gaming in New
Hampshire is the only state that
requires this particular printing option
be
available thank you
questions thank you uh yes
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question so on average how many
tickets does the average player
pull uh that's not necessarily a
question that can be answered you'll
have a player that sits down for 20
minutes and might play through you know
40 electronic plays you might have a
player that sits down for 3 hours and
plays through a thousand
um the fact of the matter is having the
printing still have to be an option if
that printer that is in the base of the
cabinet malfunctions for any reason
especially if a player is in the middle
of play not that it happens that often
but it can it puts that machine in out
of out of operation so the player is not
able to cash or or um pull their ticket
collect their ticket from their
Redemption ticket from the machine until
that machine is functional
again follow up follow up so if a player
wanted a paper ticket
is a printer available to hook up
quickly or is that not an option the
printers are always available so if a
player wanted to print out the ticket
they they do have right now currently
the option to just play the ticket and
then request the the machine print out
that paper slip but because that is the
requirement that that printer has to be
available for the machine to operate if
it does not operate for whatever reason
it puts that machine out of operation
mhm so because because the printer has
to be functioning on that device it's
always available to the player but the
players never use uh last followup
followup so if uh Jupiter and Mars align
and there's a solar
eclipse thank
you all right I
think I'm in the dark about that one
thank you very much thank you for your
testimony thank you all right is there
any anyone else would like to testify
testify on S SP
597 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on
s597 okay um we have one more public
hearing uh but before I do that I want
to jump back and uh reopen the exec
session which I believe should be fairly
quick on S sp513 uh open that back up we
have an amendment uh being passed
out
so the amendment being passed out
removes that one reference to the RSA
that we talked about
previously does anybody have uh
any
question looks pretty straightforward
representative PL I move to adopt Senate
Bill 513 not to
pass
second all right second represent
Southworth Shamburg
yeah I just want to recognize
representative Southworth once in a
while
discussion um I'm going to hear about
the amendment we'll discuss the amended
Bill uh you need to introduce the
amendment all right I'll introduce the
amendment uh I move the adoption of
amendment
number
1453 second Mr
chairman would you like to speak to the
amendment uh soon as I write it
down yes uh thanks to the uh brilliant
work of our two attorneys on the on the
uh committee we have struck
language uh referring to a uh section of
Statute that just confused everybody so
now it's clear that any charitable
organization no matter what type uh can
engage in this service and it it was
already in law that they didn't have to
be licensed now it makes clear that the
the uh the uh the person they hire the
auctioneer also doesn't need a license
for this
purpose
representative spillsbury I should have
recognized you uh given the work you've
done on this I apologize nothing to add
except I appreciate the good working
relationship with my colleague
representative
Ames thank
you repres representative Ames and I
gave you
credit
concurs okay uh seeing no more questions
the clerk will call the
role
all right
okay I shall now do so this is on the
amendment 1453 H uh for Senate Bill 513
and I'll start with the Cor
representative uh du ducet yes
representative oler yes representative
Ammon yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes represent ORS
yes represent of roord yes uh represent
uh a
poch
pusic not
here uh representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative
Bolton I'm not
[Music]
here representative elberger
yes representative leapley yes
representative
Smith not
here
um uh and uh the chair yes so the vote
is
1703 not
voting
okay we'll now move on to the bill as
amended do I have a motion from
representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chair I move otpa on 530
do I have a second
second now you guys said second at the
same time so now
it's South representative Southworth
seconds
it representative spillsbury would you
like to speak to your
motion enough said thank
you all right seeing no more discussion
the clerk will call the role when he's
as soon as he's ready
all right uh yes representative set yes
uh representative uh uh representative
oler yes
uh uh representative Ammon yes
represent spillsbury yes represent plots
yes representative sodi yes
representative ores yes represent of
rord yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes represent shamber yes
represent fellows yeses
Bolton not here not here yeah I knocked
that down to representative elberger
yes representative leapley yes the chair
yes the vote is uh
17 Z three not
voting the vote being 170 do I have any
objections to
consent seeing none this will be placed
on
consent
and I'll close the exec session on S
sp513 I just want to thank
representative spillsbury and represent
Ames once again for doing a lot of work
this weekend to so that we were able to
pull this off and uh get this done thank
you okay now we're on our last order of
business I'm going to open the public
hearing on
SB
and once again I'll recognize
representative uh I'm sorry Senator Lang
thank you Mr chair in case you forgot I
am Senator Lang I uh serve as a senator
from Lakes Region District 2 um I'm here
to present uh Senate Bill
585 um 585 is a pretty straightforward
bill um currently when a restaurant is
behind on its uh rooms and meals tax or
meals and rentals tax I guess it's
called now um that that tax if it's
owned by an LLC if the entity that
restaurant is owned by an
LLC um Dr can apply a lean a personal
lean on everyone's personal property
who's a member of that
LLC however if that same restaurant is
owned by a corporation and you have
Equity investors the only people that
can be applied to the propert private
property lean are the op are the um
operating the president of the
corporation as well unless there was
been an asset transfer and if there's an
asset transfer recorded by the
corporation anybody who got um any
stockholder who got assets is also
liable for the rooms and meals tax so
the uh goal of this bill is to treat L
LLC similar to our corporations if you
have a passive investor which is non
uncommon in New Hampshire for restaurant
um they have no role in how the
restaurants run they they were asked to
put up some money to help open up the
restaurant so they put up the money
their goal is that in three five years
they get their money back with some
interest and but they have no
operational um responsibilities within
the restaurant in of itself um the goal
is not to have that private LLC passive
investor be responsible and have their
personal house um put up on a put a lean
up on for it so they're treated s
similar to a corporation as a passive
investor an equity investor in a
corporation in a restaurant
um that's the whole bill in a nutshell
again it's to reduce leans um of private
investors in LLC that are passive in
nature again provided there was no asset
transfer and they're not um responsible
for the operation so they're not um the
managing partner they're not the uh
they're not the chef or the or the
manager the the of the restaurant itself
um they could not be held personally
liable for their personal
property I will say that it requires G
to do a little more work but I would
hope if you're going to put a a lean on
a piece of private property you would do
the work to make sure you're putting a
lean on the right person's property
rather than just
everybody thank you questions
representative
Erie yeah oh represent arm
me I'm not
ol no I and you me
on I I wanted to
understand how you Define
management you have restaurants that are
um
owned uh at 51% interest uh of the of
the restaurant is owned on by owns five
different
restaurants are they cons the person
that owns most of it but isn't
necessarily the
manager of each
restaurant on is it the guy that he
hired to be the manager in the
restaurant the manager or is the guy
that owns the majority of the shares in
the LLC so again if they're responsible
for the management of the LLC officer or
there's been an asset transfer they
would be
liable
so he had somebody who owns five
different
restaurants or I know one that owns more
than that um at least one and but he
leaves the management to them and just
checks the books every now and then or
something or just takes the checks um he
has no
responsibility again just being a member
of the live of the LLC would not
automatically subject you to the lean
even if you own most of it I'm sorry
even if you own most of the
business again that may be again if
you're a passive investor and you're
just a member of the LLC not actively
engaged in the running of the business
you would not be subject to the lean the
goal is to spur investment in our our uh
hospitality
industry so if you've got 15
McDonald's on then it would be the local
person who is having to do everything
that they told him to do from
McDonald's um who would be responsible
for not having gotten the checkout in
time
I'm not sure I understand your
question
on well I thought I like if I can
interject representative we have uh
someone from Dr maybe yes I know I know
I wanted to ask them
too
but I thought I'd give the sponsor a
chance representative flet
then I I'm reading the bill which is I
know not very smart thing to do and it
doesn't match with what you said the
intent of the bill was because I don't
see anywhere in there P you can point it
out refers to a passive investor it just
says that lean shall be applied and it
will be include any
person
uh could be somewhere in there about
with a manager uh managerial capacity
president trees other person or
managerial capacity so it lean could be
applied to the people running the
business but I don't see anything about
uh a passive investor and there would
explain please so again that's that's it
used to say in uh so again on line 11 of
the bill that the two words that are
struck out there includes members and
those members who are not active in the
managerial capacity of the LLC could be
are the passive investors and we're
taking those members out and just
talking about the persons in the man
managerial capacity of LLC do that
answer your question
maybe it would be clearer it said it
explicitly said if someone's a passive
investor they're not included so in an
LLC you have members right versus a S
Corp or a C Corp we all have Equity
owners and so in LLC everybody's a
member although you have managerial
members as well and so the point is if
you're just a passive member of an C
because you provided an equity you
provided an in uh some in revenue for
the purpose of opening the restaurant
doesn't make you subject to it just
being a member by in and of in and of
itself represent erery followed by
fellows um Senator so your contention is
that by striking the word member um
you're eliminating all of the by
definition under the LLC law passive
individuals then by putting the word
managerial in there which is an
undefined term under
LLC who are the managers because the
director doesn't necessarily need to be
a member and yet the director is the one
doing the day-to-day stuff so should
should we add director and other
managerial members I'll just remind you
this isn't new law this is existing law
what I've done is I've struck the word
member and and the word
three words right so that it makes it
clear that leans are applied to again
under current law any person in a manage
capacity of a limited liability company
so that's current law I'm not adding
that to statute what I'm doing is I'm
striking the members and making it clear
it's the managerial U members of an LLC
that are
responsible follow up follow
up who's a managerial member if it's not
find in either the LLC law or this law
Dr is coming up I'm sure you can they
again this is law that they already have
this isn't new definition a person in a
managerial capacity of a limited
liability company has current law I'm
not adding that so they've already made
that determination already do make that
determination some way shape or form
under current
law thank
you okay let me get the there's a lot of
questions let me get the order straight
here I think fellows is next
uh yes represent so if I wanted to know
who are these people you know so there's
an LLC out there you know a restaurant
LLC and how will would I know who are
the members and the person in a
managerial capacity and also this is a
lean on
property the LLC not own any property
somebody the wife of one of the members
might own the property so how do you
address that so again that's a true
statement um I I again this is not new
law um only thing we're doing in this
law is removing the word members which
are the passive investors not actively
engaged in the management of the LLC
that's the only thing this is doing the
law current exists so Dr is already
making these determinations and already
applying leans um um to the two people
the only difference is we don't want
them to apply leans to passive investors
who are not active in um how the
businesses run or anything else they
provided a an upfront bunch of money so
they can open up a restaurant and then
the restaurant goes sideways and it's up
the Dr to determine who's responsible
for that and and to make sure the leans
go to those persons again there's
already under current law under current
process under Equity investors for the
purposes of a corporation they make the
same determination um if there's an
asset transfer in a corporation of of
assets of the corporation to a private
to a equity owner that automatically
makes the Equitable Equitable owner
subject to a lean so Dr is making these
determinations
already okay um I don't know who was
first Southworth or leapley but leapley
representative
leapley thank you Mr chair I two
questions um thanks for taking my
question Senator Lang um I have two
questions the first one is what problem
is this solving so again so in cases of
we have passive investors who had no
actual idea of running the business they
just gave some money to an LLC and said
run the business in 5 years I'll see you
I'll get my profit back um and in the
meantime that business didn't pay their
rooms of meals tax and now that private
investor has nothing to do with how the
business is running they just gave them
money is getting their private property
attached for the liability that the
restaurant owns thank you my second
question is my understanding of a member
in an LLC is a someone who can receive
profit from an LLC and it seems to me
that it doesn't matter very much if
you're involved in managing the company
or not if you're responsible for not
having paid those taxes but you should
have a lean placed on your property if
you receive profit or are in line to
receive profit from a business so to me
it seems like the bill is appropriate as
it's laid out so again I think that goes
back into the phrase of transfer of
assets so if the money is transferred to
you then they could apply a lean to you
but if you haven't gotten received any
money and you're not part of that
operation of the event again there's
times where a restaurant will receive
and and there are people here from the
hospitality injury probably speak a way
more better to this than I can but my
understanding is there are passive
investors put money into the they have
no operational um controls over the
business other than they put investment
money in and and the ideaas they should
not be subject to a private lean but
going back to what member clut
said what the bill says is includes
members and and you're striking
members correct so it's only managerial
or people have had assets transferred to
them so the bill that you're asking us
to pass would make it so we can't put a
lean on
anyone who on the people who are in line
to receive profits from a company who
didn't pay their taxes that we should
wait until the profit is transferred to
that um that member and then we could
put a lean on their on their property so
I just say that's exactly what happens
in a
corporation right again in a in a
corporational aspect of it my
understanding Dr I'm sure will correct
me if I'm wrong um but um we only go
after the officers or where there's been
an an asset transfer do you so you think
that's the correct way of doing things
and so the Improvement to the law would
be to correct how we handle llc's and
not correct how we handle corporations I
think we handle corporations
appropriately again to encourage
investment into the hospitality industry
in New
Hampshire thank
you senator I I have a question so as
the bill
um you know if a manager if a lean was
placed because of a manager's failure to
pay um that's only on the property of
the business not on the personal
property it's personal property that's
the whole point of this is that it's
it's your home is being attached okay
and you're saying this has always been
this way and all you're doing is
removing the idea that a member who
might be a passive investor um would
have their home could not have their
home attached correct thank
you uh now down here representative
Southworth I'll ask the Dr as well
thanks for taking my question so the
goal initially is to collect the taxes
for the state and so forth the original
Law um will won't this change make it
harder for the state to collects the the
taxes that are
due again if I guess the answer is yeah
sort of it could
um the uh idea again being is the person
responsible should be the person who has
the lean placed on them right so it it's
a passive investor you may have no
responsibility at all in the in the LLC
and yet now you're being subject to it
just because you loaned your friend some
money to start a
restaurant and now your personal house
is going to be attached because your
friend screwed it up understand that but
again just to reiterate it's going to
make it harder for the really the state
to become whole and collect its taxes I
just think it takes more due diligence
that they'd have to make sure the right
that they're attaching the lean to the
right person yeah and they still get it
back because it's not stopping them from
doing I'll ask them that question too I
think they are probably diligent but
I'll ask them thank
you I mean the other possib I just throw
this out another possibility might be um
that passive investors passive members
could be excluded as opposed to members
because some members can be active
active members probably ask that I don't
know that there's a delineation in law
of passive versus active members I don't
think there's a delineation that's why
we struck members and just said
managerial is responsible the people who
manage the LLC is responsible and their
private property could be attached okay
person who's not actively managing the
LLC is not should not be attached
representative ORS thank you Mr chair
and thanks for taking my question I'm
sure Dr can answer this if you can't but
it sounds to me like this bill goes hand
inand with current law SAR Baines Oxley
where those that are responsible cannot
claim ignorance and therefore they're
held accountable correct so that's the
whole goal if you're a management you're
responsible for it you should do it but
if you're someone over here who not not
actively engag don't even know not NE
they wouldn't even know that the rooms
of meals tax weren't pay paid until all
of a sudden they got a lean attached to
their house absolutely
brilliant I I will say this passed out
of the Senate four to one bipartisan and
out of my committee and then it was a
Voice vote on the senate
flooor representative Amy or no
representative Aly thank you um
does would you object if we um amended
this to require the the Secretary of
State's office I guess it is to include
the information about who is passive and
who is not uh in the annual report that
the businesses are supposed to make
which I hope they are making because
they didn't used to having not thought
about that before this moment um I'd be
I'd be hesitant to make a definitive
statement but again I think that Dr is
easily able to make that uh assessment
again because they already have in law
the idea of who the managerial person is
for an LLC it's in current
law representative
fellows thank you if if somebody um was
asked to invest in the LLC become a
member of the LLC and if they were
concerned about their their property you
know being liable to seizure if the new
LLC didn't make any money um wouldn't
they have the option to just loan money
to the to the LLC and um at a certain
interest rate so aren't they kind of
like getting in this you know they they
should know what they're getting into
right there are multiple ways again
multiple ways to uh invest that way that
you're talking about whether it's a
direct loan or whether it's uh part of
an LLC um so the answer your question I
guess is yes you could do it either
way and I would I would expect that if
you were that concerned you would become
an active member in the LLC and be
involved in the management of it if you
were that concerned about getting your
money
back represent representative ORS
followed by llee thank you Mr chair uh
thanks for taking my question so
followup to representative Amy as far as
identifying the players uh wouldn't that
be easily done within annual audits of
the I would expect so again that's
probably a Dr question rather than me um
I know that when I had my LLC I had to
file paperwork and my name was all over
it so obviously I would be subject to a
lean if I was in the hospitality
industry um but so again I don't think
it's necessarily hard to signed mhm so
followup followup so businesses are
going to do an annual audit I would
assume correct they have to I don't know
that the annual audit is public though
so again because we're talking about
private llc's right so I don't know that
an audit would be public like that but
your filings with the state are public
so when the LLC has to file its
paperwork for bet BPT that's all public
documentation public these are good
questions for Dr yeah I think we should
move on for okay yep very good thank you
representative
lley thank you for taking my question um
again I'm just confused by the by the
terms of active and passive are these
when an LLC fills out paperwork to form
itself with the state are is are those
terms used again I already answered that
question for the chairman those aren't
that's why I'd be worried about putting
them into laws because we don't have it
that's why I don't use the word active
and passive I struck the word members
making sure that the leans are only
applied to managerial persons of the LLC
I guess what I'm getting at is is I'm
not sure
how law is concerned with Define
defining things and that we're all
talking about the same thing and it
seems like in this bill we're striking
member and your claim is that it's a
passive member but I don't understand
how the Dr
would understand which members were
active and passive unless it's defined
somewhere in
writing so again that's current law
I I just keep saying that it's on on
line 11 the law already says um for the
purpose of this section operator in the
case of Corporations includes a
president treasur D operators in the
case of a limited liability company
includes any person managerial capacity
of the limited liability company that's
what the new law would read and that's
already current law we just struck three
words from current law the words members
and an other that's that's what this
bill does is Strike those three words
and leaves the rest of the existing law
to make it so that it's the person in a
managerial capacity of the limited
liability company which gr must be able
to know because it's a current
law so the question follow up is this I
mean again so is this a Dr question
follow question is your
intention it I'm trying to true the
presentation with the rules with the
words that are used in the bill because
current law says members and and I know
what a member is because that's defined
and when we fill out paperwork as an LLC
it says members so I understand what a
member is so to strike that it sounds a
little bit like people who stand to make
profit are
protected from being liable for a tax
bill that is due and that those people
aren't responsible the only people who
should be held responsible are the
people who failed to pay the tax bill in
my understanding that's your intention
with this bill intention on private lean
is to say that it includes any person in
a manager capacity of the LLC they're
liable for the lean that is my intent
okay so it doesn't matter who is making
profit from the business it's my intent
to make the people responsible who pay
the bill that run the business to be
responsible for the lean and be held for
the lean that because it didn't get paid
okay I just am confused because we have
a thing called a business profits tax
where we tax profits so thank you okay
thank you
Senator uh next I we got
Henry vo
ve thank you uh Mr chairman man and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Henry veu and I'm here
on behalf of the New Hampshire lodging
and Restaurant
Association um the association uh is the
one that asked Senator Lang uh to put
the bill in um and what I thought was
pretty
simple um I think has raised a lot of
questions you can see here um but here
here's the instance that we are trying
to addess and this is really going to
impact the small
operators uh so an instance where John
wants to start a
restaurant John uh asks his parents for
some money to help open the
restaurant um John is obviously the one
in the managerial
capacity um it's his restaurant um
John doesn't pay the rooms of males
tax um under today's uh scenario with
this uh Dr can go after John's assets
and the parents assets even though the
parents aren't really involved in the
day-to-day
operation um which is different from a
corporation because under the statute
today
it
says for the purposes of this
section
operator uh which is going to be the
entity that's going to be responsible
for the tax operator in the case of a
corporation includes the president
Treasurer and any other person in a
managerial capacity of S corporation so
that's what's in the current law and
then it says operator in the case of a
limited liability company includes
members which the parents would be and
any other person in a managerial
capacity of the limit liability company
so we're just trying to put Corporation
and an LLC on the
same um footing with regards to uh
potential tax lean uh for unpaid taxes
um you can ask the a lot of these
questions I think you should ask the
department um in terms of how do they
figure out who's in a managerial
capacity um I think they are best to
answer that um I don't think this occurs
a lot um and when we're talking about
llc's we're talking about smaller
operations uh I think any unpaid taxes
from a corporation potentially could far
exceed what you would potentially occur
in an LLC so that's the instance that
this is trying to uh address and thank
you represent elme the difference
between corporations other difference
between the corporations and
llc's is that
a on I I've known in people that have
set up uh one of them 25 llc's
and I know that people set up one LLC
for the parking garage and another LLC
for the lot and another uh LLC for the
restaurant and another for the hotel on
so that they'd protect one from the
other when someone was suing and doesn't
that apply in this case also that you
could have you could have an
LLC that uh for a restaurant that had
subdivided all the other functions of it
and you couldn't put a lean on anything
except the restaurant
itself which may be losing
money I'm not sure I understand the
question the question is couldn't that
occur where again on if if um somebody
set up a restaurant but on the parking
lot for that restaurant was in a
separate
LLC and a third part of it um the the
food provision was another
LLC on and so forth that when you put a
lean on it the only thing you could put
it on was the Central Restaurant rather
than all the other parts of what is one
business
um again uh this what what we're trying
to address is an
investor a small the guy wants to start
a restaurant he can't get the total loan
from the bank they want someone else to
take the risk parent puts the uh puts uh
some money in there and uh this is just
to try to protect that type of
investment represent Ellery thank you
thank you for taking my question we're
talking about llc's only in this
particular instance yes
c23 already exempts members and managers
or directors from liability all
liability any debt any
source so that is the cas what it says
in law except when it when it comes to
the rooms of males tax um so we so I I
get what you're saying we had uh one of
the Premier tax attorneys at the she
Infinity Law Firm who practiced this
this stuff and he says yes what exactly
what you're saying is true most people
when they think they're investing in an
LLC that they are immune that they are
in the same situation you're talking
except when it comes to the rooms of
meals tax and you might want to ask the
department that too so it is true except
for the rooms of meals
TXS follow up okay yeah that's a
question I see them writing them back
so um I don't quite understand that
however what's your definition of a
manager I see Dunkin Donuts out there
offering shift managers
positions all of the the chains are for
them but it's it's not defined in anywh
so I think the intent and again the
department can probably respond because
its current law is someone in a
managerial position of managing the
company represent Ames yeah I just
wanted to say that I really think we
need Dr up we're going around in circles
and we're not talking I agree to the
enti that's really responsible for this
that has the history of interpretation
of this phrase and so forth I agree
thank you for your testimony all right
thank
you and now we'll invite up Dr I've got
a card for Keen mang Wang and then
another card that says Department of
Revenue so whoever from the Department
uh wants to come up uh come on
up and uh introduce yourselves when
you're
settled I'll start good morning
committee members my my name is oral
mayor I'm the assistant commissioner of
the Department of Revenue Administration
could you tell your name oh I'm sorry o
a last name is lamir l e m e r e
assistant
commissioner I was formerly the
collections director for six years so
I've decided to accompany our te main
Wong tax policy
Council good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Keen Ming Wong tax
policy counsil with the new Department
of Revenue um the the department does
not have a position on this bill um
however the department does have
concerns about uh the impact on the
passage of this bill uh specifically as
what has been discussed uh today is uh
in terms of the collectability of taxes
that's owed to the state um essentially
I just wanted to to to back up and
probably just uh remind uh committee
members that the M&R tax is a tax that's
Essen Al levied on the customers it's
not a tax that is levied on the M&R
operators it's not a tax that's deit on
the uh the restaurants or the hotels
it's a tax that's paid by the customers
and it is
collected upon the customers paying the
bill so when uh when you go to a
restaurant you pay your bill after the
meal um that tax is collected at that
point by The
Operators and that tax is collected on
half of the state so it does not belong
to the operators and the following month
on the 15th of the following month that
tax is then uh required by law to be
remitted by The Operators to the state
and essentially to the
Dr um and so uh as as it happens
potentially um people who uh operators
who have this money in hand um for
whatever reason does not remit this uh
tax that has already been collected that
is that belongs to the state to the
state on the 15th of the following month
then U the Dr um and then if they they
do report that that okay they they
they've collected this amount of tax and
they have limitted only x amount of tax
um there a shortfall um then the Dr
would uh start the process in terms of
trying to collect the the outstanding
taxes that's also the audit process
that's involved and let's say if um if
there are operators who report rep a
certain only a certain amount and pay
that certain amount but then um when
there is an audit process that involves
and then the Dr finds out that there
additional taxes that's owed and then
that's that's another process however um
with the lean uh process that's uh based
on this bill here essentially uh this
lean is a lean on The Operators uh well
on the assets of the operat the property
of The Operators it's it's a the section
of the bill uh once if you you read that
carefully it's not a lean on the um
assets of the U the LLC or or the
corporation it's a lean on the assets of
the prop of the uh of The
Operators um and then the Dr does go
through a lengthy process before any
lean uh is issued or attached to any
kind of property um the the collections
division would make phone calls to um to
The Operators uh Dr the Dr the
collections division would make field
visits to the operators asking them you
know just to follow up on the payments
um letters would be issued out to the um
to The Operators to remind them to pay
um and then the final I guess the uh uh
the find the last alternative would be
if that has the operators has not been
responsive in terms of trying to work
with the Dr to come up with a payment
plan or or trying to have any kind of um
showing any initiative to to trying to
settle the uh the outstanding amounts
then and only then would a lean uh be
taken would be uh
registered
um I will just I will just add um excuse
me um that with the collections process
again Keen mentioned all of the tools in
our tool kit but there is also a level
of judgment that's applied that we do
look toward the active members if you
will and I know the statute does not
clarify and I'll kind of preempt the
question the Secretary of State's office
does not define who is active and
passive but we do um in contact with
that restaurant over months or any type
of period we do tend to know who is
managing that company and if it's a
storefront manager who handles that
daily cash that that's responsible for
the deposit to the bank that's obviously
where we would start um we do dis
discuss the terms with any of the LLC
members uh active or not we explained
the process to them it is written on our
application and defined in all of our
forms that they would be personally
responsible when it does come to the
time where we need to collect we will
make an attempt every time to work it
out from the bottom up I mean we want to
obviously contact the right person um
and that includes negotiating you know I
understand that a parent may be involved
on behalf of his or her son but they
also are an LLC member and do have an
opportunity to get involved in that
business and to know the actions of
their son but we would start with
the represent spillsbury
thank you Mr chair so I'm looking for an
analogy and I think uh the distinction
that you pointed out is just so
essential meals and rentals tax is a tax
on the
customer so the restaurant took or
operator is in a custodial relationship
Visa the
Dr right this is essentially the same
relationship as applies where you have
an income tax a personal income tax and
withholding no we don't have that in New
Hampshire so it's not so much in our
wheelhouse locally but when a similar
situation occurs with the
IRS and a business has withheld
uh the employees portion of their
payroll
taxes what exactly is the situation
there when it comes to C corporations
for guidance here and I think part of
what's going on in this statute is the
statute doesn't
clearly Define
operator it it includes a sentence that
says in the case of a a C corporation
dot dot dot and it includes a sentence
that says in the case of an LLC dot dot
dot but as our um the prior um speaker
indicated uh the whole essence of
Corporations is limited
liability so the question as
representative oler suggested is you
would start with the presumption that
you can't pierce the corporate veil and
assign liability to investors whose only
interest is is monetary is so what does
the IRS do in exactly this
situation when payroll taxes are not
remitted uh that's a very good question
I I've never looked into that how the
IRS would address this um but I think
what I can say is that uh this statute
has been around since
1995 uh and that is um 93 was when the
New Hampshire first adopted the LLC
statute and then in 95 it's when uh the
uh in the M&R statutes that they looked
okay there's this new organization that
that New Hampshire is recognizing so um
then this additional language is placed
into the uh the lean statute uh in
addition to what was already there for
corporations good history I appreciate
that
context uh representative PL yes I'm
trying to understand the impact of this
bill and I heard uh assistant
commissioner lamir state that when it
does get to the proc uh the point of
leans after having tried every other
aspect that a level of judgment is
applied so you're going after the
despite the law covering everybody that
you would apply it to the sensitive
managers the people responsible for
running the business so what what impact
does this bill have on your
collectibility well there is some impact
thank you for the question but just to
give you a big picture there have been
since the beginning of the fiscal year
about two 20600 collections cases
created cases that flow down through an
assessment to collections of that amount
between July and now less than 5% are
meals and rentals lead that have been
placed out of that that pool 5% or less
are meals and rentals and an even lower
percentage of those leans that have been
placed on meals and rentals operators
are applied as LLC operators or to LLC
members if you will so it's a very small
pool um but it is a a tool that we have
available to us again we've try
everything to collect debt phone calls
repeat phone calls field visits payment
plan
options when we do get to the point of
placing a lean with a trust tax tax
especially we do look to um those
responsible parties as we call
them I also just want to add that um I
believe that our collections um efforts
are only as good as the information that
we are able to get from the U The
Operators um the information that we get
uh from uh from an
LLC operator uh we cross check that with
the information that we have that we're
able to get from Secretary of State and
the information that is available from
the Secretary of State for the annual
return filings of the LLC is at most
probably listing of one manager or one
member um and then uh when The Operators
apply for an uh for a M&R license uh we
do require that the operator or the the
business lists down um all the uh the
members and all the people with manager
capacity um with the uh with with the
form so um we can only do so much but
we're relying on the information that we
we have um and then when when The
Operators are not responsive in terms of
trying to work with us in uh for
collecting a tax that has they have
already collected and should be remitted
to the the state just the following
month um and we after we've gone through
all the process in terms of trying to
collect this money and contacting these
these uh operators um I think the final
um is the the the final route would be
to to issue a lean and then but to whom
the leans would go to then we would just
rely on that information that we have we
can't um I think representative Army
just now presented a very good
suggestion in terms of should we require
the Secretary of State to require that
all llc's to register uh when they
register with the uh with the state or
when they file the annual returns to
list all members with manager capacity
that might be helpful because um when we
contact the uh The Operators they may
not be providing us with all that
information so that we can specifically
identify which specific member has the
has the manager capacity and we don't we
don't want to lose out in terms of
collecting the money from the state
because that's the money that they
already took from the
customers thank
you representative
Southworth thank you for taking my
question just want to get the numbers
correct so um the scope of this is about
5% or less of the people that need
collections followup so it's not of all
the businesses it's just that smaller
group that need collections followup and
then it's you know less than 5% you get
to the lean
level right the entire group that I was
referring to to is the collections so
it's a very small part of very small yes
portion that actually gets a lean placed
follow follow up and I assume part of it
you mentioned it briefly you do have
options to offer them along the way oh
definitely so it really is a a what do I
want to say it's really the final
alternative right okay that's helpful
thank you repres now representative Erie
uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
Chun
um the
remission failure to make that remission
is that a civil or criminal
activity uh it could be a criminal
activity I would presume it's
statutorily required that meals and
rentals operators remit that tax monthly
okay follow up follow up if it's either
one but especially if it's Criminal
there has to be an individual who
willfully took undertook an action an
individual who willfully undertook an
action not the
LLC but an individual who knowing that
money belonged to the state and whose
responsibility it was to transmit it was
a sole
individual not the LLC not any
member which is why 30423 take c23 takes
place to isolate them from an individual
who was essentially stealing from the
state it would be no different than if
that individual was taken from the till
what you want what's your question
representative is that correct okay
um yeah
um
so we're not uh prosecuting attorney so
I it's just very difficult for us to
answer that question but I just want to
go back to the point that um that was
also mentioned uh during this hearing
before uh that the uh the
llc's they have members and members have
access to the the profits from the llc's
so essentially I'm trying to uh to
imagine that this activity of lean we're
not leaning anything more than what the
taxes owed or the interest of the
penalty and essentially this is I would
aen this to a to a to an action of
trying to discor
the profits that's unrightfully kept by
the members or or whomever because they
have access to the profits of of the uh
of the LLC and um and therefore
returning that money back to the
state thank you for the question
representative ER it it's actually a
great Point um I will point out that in
recent years when I was the collections
director that the the there is not very
often just a sole individual involved
there could be a manager again who's
taking those deposits daily to the bank
um who reports those to you know um a
corporation or as rep representative Aly
pointed out it could be a string of ll's
that you know are funneling that money
we did have some re recent court cases
where there were a number of individuals
that were determined to be held liable
in an L LLC situation and I don't have
the references in front of me but I
could get that information for you
um Mr chair follow up yeah yeah I would
yes I I would appreciate that
information and I would would appreciate
the uh the uh
chenan uh um comment as well uh the
question then from your testimony thus
far revolves back to an undefined term
as to what a manager is or what
management is as because it it doesn't
exist either in the tax section or in
the LLC section there ain't no such
credit um in in in addition to
that I'd like to know on the contract
that you
sign for the
remittance if that does not put the
individual signing the contract
personally liable for the remission of
remission of the funds it does it
doesn't it does it does well
there's your
guy on the um I'll just clarify on our
application it's a CD3 form you can get
it online there are a number of boxes we
look for the person who's managing the
company LLC it could be you know a
relative or it could be someone that's
hired we do look for the manager as well
as we include and the statute's clear
that it includes members and anyone in a
managerial capacity it's not limited to
the one person there's no manager in an
LLC well there's a there there is a
manager there can be a member managed or
a a manager managed LLC there can also
be no um managers uh well member
managers but there are passive investors
who put a manager at a storefront to do
the daily operations we look for that
person who's on location as well as LLC
members who are behind the scenes
collecting those
profits representative
do you think it would help to
uh further Define managerial capacity in
this statute and if so do you have
suggestions
thank I I think that would be helpful
but I think the uh the con the core of
dr's concern is just trying to
to identify those people in the manager
capacity and then
um because right now as as as it
currently stands we rely on information
from the Secretary of State and then um
information that's been filed with the
Dr um and it it may not be as complete
as as uh as as we would like in terms of
trying to when when when it comes to
trying to to administer the the
collections of the uh of the taxes I
have a I have a question and I'll come
back to you um so as it stands now the
current law let's say you have an LLC
there's five members they're not paying
the M&R tax do you put one lean on each
of them or how does that work the Lan
gets placed in full on each member and
the LLC first The Entity first and the
amount of the lean that's filed is
against each member and the entity okay
thank you we will work out obviously
with you know payment arrangements and
we will determine sometimes there are
k1s that we refer to to see who holds
what interests but we typically would
expect them to as members you know um
work that out between them right thank
you representative
Ames yeah I just
uh ask that you consider the question I
asked and whether um there is
some remedy to this uh apparent problem
of uh putting all the weight on
the managerial concept managerial
capacity concept that now is the core
concept for an LLB in terms of you're
placing a lean and whether um whether a
better definition of that is uh going to
move us to a better place or um a uh
additional
requirement for filing with you or with
the Secretary of State might uh might be
helpful um and just uh I think if we if
you could think about this and get back
to us that might be
helpful okay thank
you representative fellows um thank you
um my concern is the concept of manager
because in in most restaurant if you say
if you say the restaurant down the road
who's the manager of that people think
of it as being the person at the top of
the totem pole of the
employees or it could be the owner but
they're in that restaurant essentially
most of the time and that if if somebody
in the restaurant is diverting those
payments you know I don't know somehow
saying they're taking them and
depositing them in the bank but they're
not they're putting it in their pocket
that could be the manager it could be a
lower employee and that is that is theft
and they should be prosecuted for that
but in terms of the business which is
owned by the partners collectively from
that's my way to make a distinction here
then they're the owners of the business
and they're the ones that are
responsible for what the manager does
and all the other employees I mean you
don't know maybe they maybe the owners
maybe they have somebody in the members
that tells the manager okay we want you
to give us the cash in that comes in
every day I mean it's not now it's
mostly credit cards but anyway suppose
it was all cash and that we're going to
take care of paying the bills you know
they've got an accountant somebody else
is paying the light bills that so my
question is I am concerned that do you
have that concerns about identifying
somebody as the manager it seems to me
that it's it doesn't even belong in
here I thank you for the question
representative I think it's important
that you acknowledge that there could be
two types of managers right there's a
manager at the location you're sitting
at a restaurant having dinner you ask to
speak to to the manager you're going to
get a person and typically that person
is responsible for the day-to-day
deposits if there was some failure to
remit those to the bank at that point
then yes they that person would be
responsible but however what if that
manager does deposit daily and it's the
person in control the manager that's in
control of the bank account or the you
know member that's in in control of the
bank account that doesn't pay the tax so
we do recognize both we do ask for
information upon the application the CD3
for any members especially the manager
who's at the location again that would
be the first
Contact and the enforcement that we did
take would start at that
level representative spillsbury
um yes thank you Mr chair this isn't so
much a question of our Witnesses but it
is in part I I think we've come to a
point where it's getting kind of
circular this is ripe for a very meaty
work session and to be prepared for that
work session now back to our Witnesses
it would be extremely helpful to have as
representative am
suggested any suggestions that you might
have regarding definitions so
particularly the definition of an
operator and the definition of a manager
or managerial capacity in this context
but also I think we need to know what
does the IRS do in that analogous
situation where effectively taxes are
withheld from employees and there's a
trust relationship that's created
there's criminal liability and all of
the ramifications that go along with
that in federal tax practice regarding
corporate entities because I do think
that what we're what we're seeing here
unmasked is a lot of ambiguity in our
existing law about different forms of uh
business ownership and Arrangement and
uh how that relates to the corporate uh
limited liability and how that relates
to um tax liability and I think this
statute is essentially making an
exception or going beyond the normal
understandings of limited liability and
that's the
frustration of our prior witness what so
I think what the bill is trying to
address is fairly clear not making
passive investors liable to have their
homes attached
um but I think that how we get there is
going to take some careful
work and the question was can you can
you bring that dat can you help us be
prepared for our work session okay you
thank you representative
leapley thank chair for taking my
question um I think the other side of
we've had a couple questions um around
that side of the information I think the
other side that we need to make sure we
have information about is if we narrow
this
legislatively does it make the dr's job
harder and I think if they could clarify
for us for I'm thinking for example I'm
not sure if this is true but I wonder if
those members aren't listed
legislatively they're not listed in the
law does that impact their ability to
negotiate with the owners right the
members making sure that pressure is put
on to get the answers that are needed so
I I want to make sure uh I'm not
convinced yet that this is an
improvement to the statute so I want to
make sure that we have all the
information from the Dr that's that's
going to reveal how if we narrow this
legislatively it might make their job
harder thank you um one one thing I was
wondering is when I look at
corporations uh in the in the statute
here it talked about how I don't know it
is exactly now but about the president
or president Treasurer or other person
in a managerial capacity so if you're a
if you're a stockholder in a
corporation this wouldn't apply to you
if it's a if it's an incorporated entity
then it's only the managers and the the
officers is that
correct I I think that's a very good
question uh representative um so just
looking at the um the wording of the
statute it says for purposes of U the
this section operated in case of
Corporation includes includes the
president Treasurer and any other uh
person's in management capacity and then
when it's an LLC includes members and
any other person's in manag Your
Capacity so
um the the term just says includes it
doesn't
exclude
um
so I think
based on the interpretation he's trying
to say that it doesn't exclude
shareholders right doesn't what it
doesn't exclude the shareholders it
would include anybody in uh any sort of
responsibility type position I see what
you're saying the word includes yeah the
word is includes okay but I think we
also need to U just bear in mind that uh
that the definition operator is defined
up further top in the uh in the statute
uh in the definition section who is an
Operator Operator is a person who who um
sister wood operates or manages uh the
the facility itself uh either the hotel
or the restaurant so there is a
definition for operators up top in the
definition section thank you we will
definitely be having a work session uh
on this but uh we'll take a couple more
questions representative fellows oh no I
it's not for a question for them I'm
just wondering if um we should for the
work session get somebody from the
Secretary of State's office because
that's where they file the the LLC
application because it seems to me we're
talking about
possibly identifying people and that
would that are responsible for the LLC
and that would be the place I would
think that it would show
up restive shamberg thank you Mr
chairman two
questions uh reading the methodology
here talks of the definition of operator
and a managerial do operators or
managerial people have to show that they
have real property to be able to file a
lean on when they fill out their
applications they do not they do not
second
question um you talk about
payments uh you you're going to have to
update all necessary tax returns and
forms and electronic Management Systems
is there any way that you can do it like
Irving debit pay when you put your card
in they take it right out of your
checking account so when they deposit
their money within the next 12 hours
it's coming back to the
state just take that under roll it
around upstairs thank you
all right I I would say my personal
opinion of that is the answer is no
because they're taking it from the
customer's credit card or customer's
debit card yeah um Mr chairman I meant
at the end of the day they got to
deposit it it's coming back out of the
representa
Aly thank you um I had three questions
that I started with and still haven't
asked on our franchises sometimes
llc's yes yeah so in that case the
principal manager because they insist on
exactly what is
done could be somebody in DC or
somewhere
on yes you're you're right so that's a
complication and
llc's are based the whole idea was to
avoid liability for one business against
another
business so what do you
do with somebody who
structured uh his restaurant so that the
parking
lot is separate from the kitchen is
separate from the dining
room goad in terms of where the leans
go I I well I'm not familiar with this
situation but I think what we need to do
is also go to who is the the license
oper who is the holder of the license um
if the holder of the license is just the
one the LLC that manages the the the
restaurant um and that would be the
operator of the
um the restaurant you think then that
that you could get into the lean on the
parking lot and things like that if I
yeah I I'm sorry I'm going to jump in
and I I think it's a good question
because you're trying to show how that
separation occurs so they are protected
from the liability right however in Mees
and rentals tax operators license we are
looking for the the the income and the
revenue from the activity which is the
restaurant portion or the the lodging
portion so we would only put a lean on
the LLC that represented the The Entity
that that collected the Reven yes not
the LLC or parking lot or another
property even though they may have
structured that so that exactly if they
go bankrupt you can't get right so we're
limited we're limited to the LLC that
collects the tax and then the third one
was in the LLC law if on the passive
investors are not getting paid for the
first five years but you are not getting
your
uh your
transfer you can't go after them ever
for that period I think it's just the
opposite that in this case we do we we
don't look for with the trustees tax in
&r in this chapter in particular there
there is no transfer necessary we don't
have to go through an audit process or a
hearing to determine where those assets
go um we would necessarily just place
the lean regardless but You' you'd place
the lane also on the passive investors
even though they aren't getting any
money back yes yes oh even if this
passes I thought that was the why this
thing was
written well I think the idea is to
again to negotiate with the person who
is responsible and again that's where we
start the lean is placed on the entity
first and that goes through a series of
steps before we determine to even place
it on an individual or individuals the
LLC is responsible and I think it's been
mentioned that that's where the
responsibility lies however if we are
unsuccessful in our attempts to collect
from the LLC itself we after placing
leans as well or realize that the LLC
does not own any property in this state
because that is also a factor um then we
would look to the responsible parties
beginning with the manager at the
location and so on thank you thank you
represent you set I should know this
thank you for taking my question I
should know this off the top of my head
do we collect M&R from airbnbs and the
like we do it just opens opens another
interesting component here
agreed okay are we complete any more
questions of
Dr I guess not thank you very much for
coming thank
you all right
cards I have no more pink cards
for S SP
585 so I'm assuming there's no one else
that would like to testify seeing none I
will close the public hearing on S SP
585 okay
so that completes uh our business today
so the question I'm sure most of you
have are when are we meeting again and
um so right now the status is we have
um just the the three bills that we did
the public hearings on today are the
only bills uh left to do something with
and for now um crossover being Thursday
we may get more uh but at this point I
see no point of meeting next week um to
uh to do these three uh most likely we
should meet the following week which
would be the what is Monday Monday's the
18th no wait a minute Monday's the 18th
isn't
it Monday
next I mean I mean next
Monday let me look let's look at a
calendar next Monday next so no I just
said we're not meeting next Monday next
next week so Monday's the 22nd and
Tuesday the 23rd I'm I'm focusing more
I think at this point on Tuesday the
23rd but I would ask that for now you
you know especially till the end of this
week so we can see what's happening hold
Monday the 22nd and Tuesday the 23rd
open with the idea that if we can get it
what we need to get done at one day I'm
going to do Tuesday the 23rd so the odds
of Monday the 22nd I think are low but I
want at least um you know so
probably okay probably the next meeting
is Tuesday the 23rd excuse me Mr chair
um that's school vacation week I don't
know if it's if it's absolutely
necessary that we meet that week I I
know I I struggled with that because um
I I think I actually sent an email like
two months ago saying we would take that
week off but my concern now is that that
would then push us
into April 30th um uh and then we are
just no April 30th is
Tuesday um and then these bills have to
be done by May 16th so there is still
time
um I I don't know I don't want to commit
right now to not doing Tuesday the 23rd
yeah
okay so yeah yes repres Mr chair I
wonder if there's some advantage in
meeting next week just to have the work
sessions because there might be
Amendment requests coming out of that
which need time to
prepare and but just have the work
sessions well the I'm thinking that
um the 20 uh I don't
know yeah we have till May 16th
um and I would have to put the request
in today if there was the thing is
Thursday we might get more bills in and
then I'll know we have public hearings
as well so I'm I'm I i' prefer not to
not to meet next
week any other any other
questions all right thank you thank you
everyone